[Música]
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a este
especial de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos super
domingo electoral en américa del sur
ecuador perú y bolivia van a las urnas
en medio de las complicaciones que ha
traído la pandemia del cobi 19 y muchos
retos políticos sociales y económicos
por delante 'ecuador allí fue realizada
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales mientras que en perú
apenas van a celebrar la primera vuelta
de unas particulares elecciones
presidenciales y también legislativas
de otra parte bolivia celebra la segunda
vuelta de unas elecciones regionales en
las que cuatro departamentos elegirán a
sus gobernadores entre ellos está el
codiciado departamento de la paz
para analizar estos comicios en américa
del sur hemos invitado a sofía cordero
ella es politóloga docente del instituto
de altos estudios nacionales está en la
ciudad de quito la capital de ecuador y
también está con nosotros julio
ascarrunz él es politólogo y analista
internacional se encuentra en la ciudad
de la paz en bolivia
nuestros invitados estarán con nosotros
para comentar los diferentes aspectos
que están en juego en estas importantes
elecciones andinas y también para
analizar algunos de los resultados
preliminares que vamos a ir conociendo
poco a poco a medida que va avanzando la
noche tan pronto vayan siendo dados a
conocer por parte obviamente de las
autoridades electorales de cada país
solamente les transmitiremos a ustedes
votos oficiales emitidos por las
autoridades nuestra redacción también
preparó una serie de reportajes para
ponerlos en contexto para explicarles
algunos puntos importantes en estos
comicios también van a estar con
nosotros los corresponsales de france 24
como es habitual en estos tres países
gustavo ortega desde la ciudad de quito
la capital ecuatoriana también francisco
zacarías en lima la capital de perú y
finalmente meriva acá en la ciudad de la
paz en bolivia
las urnas cerraron a las 5 de la tarde
hora del ecuador en este país
suramericano cerca de 13 millones de
ciudadanos estaban convocados para
elegir a su presidente entre andrés
araos economista de 36 años candidato de
la unión por la esperanza es el heredero
de rafael correa el ex presidente rafael
correa y representa también la
continuidad del socialismo del siglo 21
para ese país para ecuador su
contrincante es guillermo lazo banquero
65 años tercera vez que intenta llegar a
la silla presidencial del palacio de
carondelet en el pasado fue derrotado
por rafael correa- precisamente en el
2013 y por el actual mandatario que es
el mandatario ya saliente
lenin moreno en el 2017 vamos a ver
entonces algunos resultados preliminares
y vamos a conocer entonces cómo se está
marcando la tendencia poco a poco en
ecuador ahí tenemos algunos de los
resultados 52 puntos 76 por ciento de
los votos para guillermo lasso 47 puntos
24 por ciento
para andrés arau son el 90 punto 1 por
ciento de las mesas escrutadas de esta
segunda vuelta 91
y 2 por ciento del total de estas actas
que ya han sido contadas por el cn que
es la autoridad electoral en ecuador son
datos oficiales los que le estamos
reportando aquí en france 24
vamos entonces hasta la capital
ecuatoriana para conocer más detalles de
cómo transcurrió esta jornada ya se
encuentra gustavo ortega gustavo muy
buenas noches balance entonces de esta
jornada las urnas cerraron hace poco más
de tres horas y como vemos estaba está
avanzando bastante rápido el conteo de
los votos que tal transcurrió la jornada
buena noche para ti primero informarte
que el consejo nacional electoral ha
suspendido la cadena nacional que estaba
programada para las 20 horas y la ha
pasado para las 22 horas todo esto
porque los resultados electorales
avanzan de una manera muy rápida
nosotros inclusive hace algunos minutos
podemos conversar con el secretario del
consejo nacional electoral él me ha
asegurado que intentarán el objetivo
final será buscar ofrecer los resultados
definitivos o la mayor cantidad de
resultados definitivos que indiquen una
tendencia definitiva que no varíe para
ofrecernos el día de hoy bueno a
propósito de la pregunta inicial que tú
me hacía en una jornada electoral que ha
avanzado totalmente tranquila mucha
normalidad mucho tránsito vehícular
mucha presencia de electores en las
calles ha sido la característica el día
de hoy pero sobre todo también mi
consejo una ciudad de lectura les llama
a mantener la calma llama a esperar los
resultados oficiales a que sea el órgano
en el rector quien emite los resultados
definitivos y a pesar que no
resultados de boca de urna dan una
ventaja al candidato guillermo lasso ha
dicho que se debe esperar la calma
podemos ver inclusive en esta sala como
caminan de un lado para otro los
distintos consejeros del consejo
nacional electoral eso quería decir que
entran y salen de reuniones en cualquier
momento podrían ofrecer algún tipo de
informe específicamente en este sitio
que se ha dispuesto por parte del
consejo nacional electoral hay mucha
actividad visitas de observadores
nacionales e internacionales distintos
partidarios de las organizaciones
políticas pero hay un dato que debo
comentarte en principio el candidato
andrés allows ha emitido un
pronunciamiento él dice él insiste en
que el conteo rápido que él maneja le
daba en la victoria mientras que hay
otro conteo rápido de la empresa cedatos
les da la victoria al candidato
guillermo lazo por cuanto que andrés
araus e inclusive hecho un llamado a sus
seguidores a movilizarse a mantenerse en
las calles mientras que
los simpatizantes del candidato
guillermo lasso se mantienen reunidos en
un gran centro de convenciones en la
ciudad de guayaquil a la espera de los
resultados por el cual inclusive también
el presidente de la república más
temprano había dicho que no permitirá
ningún tipo de desmanes todo esto porque
ha llamado inclusive a los dos
candidatos presidenciales a recibir los
resultados con calma y a respetar el
pronunciamiento del órgano comicial
importante entonces retomar gustavo ese
anuncio que hiciste al inicio de la
transmisión 22 horas entonces un reporte
oficial por parte del cn intentarán dar
la mayor cantidad de avance en el conteo
de los votos puede ser ya un total de la
votación o por lo menos ya una tendencia
claramente marcada que permita definir
quién es el presidente de ecuador había
mucha presión en estos en esta segunda
vuelta sobre el cnt sobre todo después
de lo que sucedió en la primera ronda
donde el conteo fue un bastante lento y
donde hubo señalamientos de fraude por
algunos de los candidatos por eso hay
tanta presión por parte de la autoridad
electoral allí en ecuador
el llamado es a la calma esperar los
resultados oficiales del cnt la
autoridad electoral allí en ecuador
gustavo también importante para resaltar
que el ecuador no escapa de la realidad
que está viviendo suramérica del pico de
contagio de la pandemia como transcurrió
entonces esta jornada electoral en medio
de los cuidados que tenían que tener los
ciudadanos para ir a ejercer su derecho
ciudadano con todas las medidas de
bioseguridad que exigió el gobierno
cuáles fueron quién se le pidió a los
ciudadanos ya sabemos que la jornada
transcurrió en normalidad pero aparte
como transcurrió con este en estas
condiciones específicas
pero específicamente el consejo nacional
electoral lo que pedía era mantener
ampliar el distanciamiento social varias
formas muy que modificaciones que
ofreció el órgano comicial edificio de
se ampliaba en las distancias a dos
metros de un metro a dos metros para
ejercer el derecho al voto por lo menos
te puedo comentar que cuando yo fui a
ejercer el derecho al voto
había mucha división mucho espacio entre
los distintos juntas electorales para
poder acercarse a votar cuando uno se
acercaba a ejercer el derecho al voto
había que inclusive llegar a dos metros
de distancia para dictar por la mano el
número de la cédula para poder así
ejercer el derecho al voto las mesas de
votación estaban muy separadas otro dato
también que llamó la atención que era la
intención del órgano comicial era no
repetir el error que se produjo durante
la primera vuelta electoral que pudimos
ver grandes filas al inicio de las
votaciones eso fue reclamado por parte
de los electores o fermín fue tomado en
cuenta por parte del consejo nacional
electoral para evitar así las
concentraciones durante la mañana de hoy
fue un reclamo por parte de los
electores donde se estarían violando las
medidas sanitarias porque si se dieron
concentraciones y largas filas pero esto
también produjo la reacción del consejo
nacional electoral inclusive se emitió
un pronunciamiento un comunicado donde
exhortaba el cumplimiento de las medidas
finalmente también eso tenía que ver con
la hora de la instalación y en que se
activaron distintos centros de votación
un principio más del 30 por ciento se
instaló con los miembros principales de
mesas pero un aproximado del 20 por
ciento se hizo con las primeras personas
que habían en la fila o con personas
suplentes de otros centros de votación
por el cual en la jornada electoral la
principal característica fue que hubo
mucha fluidez entrada y salidas
diferentes de los electores para poder
garantizar evitar así las
concentraciones recordemos que en este
momento en el ecuador se mantiene en un
rebrote de la pandemia y específicamente
este punto fue destacado por parte de la
vicepresidenta de la república en un
discurso que ofrecía esta mañana
despidiéndose del cargo y lo que
destacaba era la realización de unas
elecciones en medio de una pandiani que
para el próximo gobierno podría contar
con 20 mil dosis contratadas para
continuar así la aplicación de las
vacunas recordemos que ecuador ha
manejado una velocidad de una presión
muy baja de vacunación a los pacientes
de kobe 19 si gustado para complementar
esta información ecuador registra más de
344 mil casos confirmados de kobe 19 al
día de hoy y han fallecido más de 17.000
personas en lo que va corrido de esta
pandemia pandemia en ese país
suramericano gracias por este reporte de
gustavo desde quitó la capital
ecuatoriana a mis dos invitados a sofía
ya julio terminó hacer la ronda con los
corresponsales y ya pasó con ustedes
para hacer el análisis de la votación en
ecuador que está avanzando muy rápido el
conteo de los votos allí voy entonces a
perú
en perú la jornada electoral fue de 12
horas comenzó a las 7 de la mañana y fue
extendida hasta las 19 horas --hora
local-- las autoridades locales
decidieron prolongar la como una de las
medidas excepcionales debido a la
pandemia de kobe y 19 en ese país
recordemos que perú es uno de los países
que está enfrentando uno de los peores
picos uno de los más altos en no está en
esta nueva ola de contagios la
presidencia dos vicepresidencias y 130
escaños en el congreso es lo que está en
juego en esta forma de electoral allí en
perú vamos hasta lima para conocer más
detalles de esta jornada francisco
zacarías está en la capital peruana para
darnos más detalles hola francisco y
pues comencemos por lo básico los
pormenores cómo transcurrió esta jornada
de votación ya hace más de una hora
cerraron las urnas allí en perú
buenas noches para comentarles que esto
ha sido una jornada completamente
atípica es la primera vez que perú va a
elecciones en medio de una pandemia y
contra todo pronóstico a pesar de las
promesas que inicialmente hicieron las
autoridades peruanas en ningún miembro
de mesa había sido vacunado porque el
proceso de vacunación ha sido lento con
la justa se ha llegado a inmunizar
solamente a 500.000 peruanos de una
población de este país que tiene más de
32 millones de habitantes muchos no
pensaron que si era bueno salir a votar
y los que eran miembros de mesa lo
pensaron doblemente si era necesario
cumplir con el deber cívico de presidir
una mesa de sufragio con el riesgo de
el contagio de el coronavirus a las
casas eso fue que lo que motivó que se
iniciara una jornada que estaba
programada desde las 7 de la mañana
hasta las 7 de la noche comenzará con
serios retrasos no solamente en lima
sino también en diversos puntos del país
se registraban largas colas y también
las quejas de
de personas de tercera edad adultos
mayores que ellos habían sido
programados de ser los primeros de ser
atendidos en los centros de sufragio de
7 a 9 de la mañana
esto motivó un retraso que desestabilizó
la programación en las autoridades se
habían previsto que el último número de
la cédula de sufragio daría el orden al
ciudadano para acudir a sufragar y esto
se concretó con largas filas y mesas que
no se armaban en los funcionarios de la
oficina nacional de procesos electorales
tuvieron que llamar a los ciudadanos con
megáfonos para que se convirtieran en
voluntarios y ellos pudieran asumir
la presidencia de los centros de
votación y aquí hay una anécdota el
lugar donde me tocó votar también hubo
demoras por más de dos horas y todos
estuvieron descontentos bueno y es que
no es para menos este incertidumbre de
este temor para salir a votar cuando el
país está presentando más de 1.600.000
casos de contagios de kobe 1954 1600
personas han fallecido allí en perú a lo
largo de este año de pandemia francisco
cuando tendremos algunos resultados
parciales por lo menos a boca de urna de
lo que ha sucedido en esta jornada
electoral hay en pero que dicen las
autoridades
comencemos por los resultados oficiales
estos se van a conocer a las 11 y 30 de
la noche que va a dar
en la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales lo que ya está
lanzado en medios de comunicación
locales son los resultados a boca de
urna que ubican al izquierdista pedro
castillo con 16.1 por ciento de los
votos estos son resultados parciales
repito hernando de soto con 11.9 quien
conjuntamente con keiko fujimori que
lleva la misma cifra y yonhy lescano con
11 por ciento compiten con un triple
empate lo sigue ellos rafael lo que
salía con 10.5 por ciento y también
verónica mendoza con ocho puntos por
ciento hay que señalar que todavía no se
puede hablar de un ganador absoluto
cualquiera puede llegar a
y tener el primer y segundo lugar a lo
largo de la contienda las encuestadoras
han detallado que los candidatos han
estado muy juntos y cualquiera puede
obtener el primer o segundo lugar esta
situación se ha producido porque en esta
contienda se han presentado 18
candidatos una cifra completamente alta
para perú y ha habido una dispersión de
votos y todavía es que los comicios se
han desenvuelto en medio del desinterés
de los ciudadanos porque la clase
política está desprestigiada debido a
que ésta ha alcanzado a los líderes
políticos y derechos ciudadanos han
votado lo que hasta este momento se
conoce con resultados parciales que
ubican en dos extremos al país en una
situación polarizada hacia la extrema
izquierda y la derecha el voto de los
peruanos
claro es un escenario particular el que
está viviendo perú pero precisamente esa
estabilidad política es lo que buscan
los ciudadanos en estos comicios
electorales hace poco más de una hora y
cuarto cerraron las urnas allí en perú
ya lo decíamos una jornada de 12 horas
que transcurrió transcurrió en total
normalidad y pues a las 11 y 30 hora del
ihma tendremos los primeros resultados
de estas elecciones disputadas entre 18
candidatos para aspirar a la presidencia
pero también hay 130 escaños para el
congreso de perú vamos entonces a
bolivia
en bolivia las elecciones son de
carácter regional cuatro gobernaciones
están en juego y es un pulso de gana o
gana para el partido oficialista el
movimiento al socialismo que encabezó en
su momento evo morales el ex presidente
de ese país y que perdió en las
elecciones algunos bastiones importantes
como por ejemplo la alcaldía de la
ciudad de el alto vamos allí no muy
lejos a la ciudad de la paz ahí está
mary vaca para conocer el detalle de
cómo transcurrió esta jornada electoral
me di muy buenas noches allí en la paz y
pues balance de esta jornada electoral
regional cuatro departamentos en disputa
por las gobernaciones
qué tal buenas noches santiago verás
noches amigos así es hemos tenido una
jornada electoral pacífica normal pero
con un alto ausentismo este dato ha sido
puesto en evidencia tanto por analistas
como por electores que han ido a las
urnas y se han encontrado que ya no
habían las tradicionales filas de
electores tratando de emitir su voto
como sucedían en las anteriores
elecciones y que la cantidad de
afluencia era mucho menor el tribunal
supremo electoral ha dicho que todavía
no puede señalar cuál es el nivel de
participación sin embargo ha advertido
que en segundas vueltas suele haber
menos afluencia de gente hay que
recordar que en bolivia el voto es
obligatorio aún no le extienden una
papeleta de sufragio que luego es
exigida para hacer trámites y también
para hacer transacciones bancarias
entonces por eso es llamativo que haya
habido poca afluencia de gente por otro
lado santiago debo comentarte que vamos
los bolivianos a irnos a dormir sin
saber quiénes son los gobernadores
ganadores de estas elecciones pues no
habrá resultados oficiales
tampoco habla habrá resultados
preliminares en cuanto a los resultados
oficiales los tribunales electorales
departamentales han empezado el cómputo
hace apenas una hora y media y el avance
es bastante lento hasta el momento están
máximo en un 8% y no se puede hablar
todavía de ganadores y los resultados
preliminares que bolivia suelen ser muy
importantes en esta ocasión no se han
emitido las empresas encuestadoras que
son contratadas por los medios de
comunicación no han hecho este trabajo
entonces será una espera a ciegas a
esperar a que el tribunal supremo
electoral tenga los resultados dentro de
los próximos siete días aunque se ha
prometido mucha agilidad esta elección
santiago es muy importante para el
movimiento al socialismo como tú lo
decías porque en la primera vuelta este
partido se ha hecho del control de tres
de las nueve gobernaciones y la
oposición de dos entonces en estas
cuatro el más que es el partido de evo
morales y luis arse se está jugando al
control territorial de las regiones y en
cambio la oposición que en realidad es
una oposición dispersa pues se tratan de
líderes
opositores diferentes no pertenecen
todos a un mismo partido están jugándose
la emergencia como fuerzas políticas de
las regiones si nos iremos a dormir sin
saber quién gana y con total
incertidumbre mary pero por lo menos
haremos análisis de este proceso
electoral que es importante para la
estabilidad política de bolivia que lo
necesita
después de ese remezón político que tuvo
después de las elecciones presidenciales
mehdi son cuatro departamentos
chuquisaca la paz pando y tarija aquí la
joya de la corona es la paz que es donde
usted se encuentra en este momento cómo
están las cargas allí ya no decía yo en
la introducción en la ciudad del alto
que es la ciudad más poblada de bolivia
era un bastión del mar y perdió esa
alcaldía el movimiento al socialismo
como están entonces allí las cargas
bueno en el caso de la gobernación
compiten el movimiento al socialismo con
franklin flores que ha ganado en la
primera vuelta pero no le ha alcanzado
los votos para ser designado gobernador
y por otro lado también compite en esta
elección santos quispe de la agrupación
hai allá debo comentarles que santos
quispe es mucho más radical que el
movimiento al socialismo en cuanto a
ideologías él es también de izquierda es
un dirigente indianista y es hijo del
mítico dirigente boliviano felipe quispe
el mallku que ha fallecido durante la
campaña electoral y le ha heredado a su
hijo está el candidatura entonces los
dos han ido a esta elección y realmente
no se sabe quién puede ganar esta
gobernación
franklin flores evidentemente ganó en la
primera vuelta pero no sabemos cuál ha
sido el comportamiento de los electores
paseños en la segunda vuelta este
ausentismo puede ser una señal de que
probablemente los opositores han tenido
poco interés en ir a votar porque se
trataba de dos fuerzas
dos fuerzas indígenas uno los dos son
aymaras entonces no había un mensaje de
parte de estos candidatos hacia la clase
media hacia la ciudad de la paz sino que
era más bien una votación o mejor dicho
unas candidaturas muy orientadas al área
rural y particularmente a los aymaras de
la paz mery pues muchas gracias por este
reporte desde la ciudad de la paz en
bolivia mery vaca informando no sé de la
jornada electoral regional allí en este
país suramericano ahora sí demos paso al
análisis electoral
bueno ya los había presentado sofía
cordero politóloga docente del instituto
de altos estudios nacionales se
encuentra en la ciudad de quito en
ecuador sofía gracias por haber dado esa
espera tenía que hacer la ronda con los
corresponsables para hacer un barrido
general de la situación en los tres
países y también está con nosotros julio
ascarrunz él es politólogo y analista
internacional se encuentra en la ciudad
de la paz en bolivia los dos gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en france 24 y
comienzo el análisis de ecuador con un
vistazo a los resultados veamos como
están entonces hasta ahora el 94% de los
votos 52 puntos 60 por ciento para
guillermo lasso mientras que el 47 punto
30 por ciento de los votos van para
andrés araus esto es información
suministrada por el cn que es la
autoridad electoral en ecuador son
resultados oficiales hasta esta hora
sofía buenas noches allí en la ciudad de
quito ya tenemos ahí unos resultados
parciales sorprendida con este resultado
cuál es su análisis
buenas noches si realmente es una
sorpresa ahora había mucha expectativa
no es una gran sorpresa pero había la
posibilidad sobre todo porque las
encuestas no daban no daban unos números
confiables y certeros es decir había una
división en los resultados de las
encuestas de unas magacines
a un candidato le daban el triunfo en
las botas tienes a otro candidato le
darán el triunfo al otro entonces íbamos
un poco a ciegas así que sí esa es una
esta es una pequeña sorpresa y julio
cuál es su percepción usted está fuera
de ecuador está en bolivia puede ver las
cosas un poco desde la distancia cuál es
el análisis que usted hace de estos
resultados parciales todo puede cambiar
o pueden aumentar o disminuir la
votación para algunos de los de los
participantes aspirantes a esta silla
presidencial sus opiniones
yo me sumo las últimas palabras de sofía
una sorpresa pero no una gran sorpresa
posiblemente es común que en escenarios
de altamente polarizados como estaba el
caso de ecuatoriano antes de las
elecciones para una segunda vuelta
electoral los resultados tienden a ser
muy estrechos y como bien decía sofía
las las las últimas encuestas no daban
un claro ganador porque se debía
considerar el margen de error y veo
difícil que haya un cambio dramático en
esta tendencia más tomando en cuenta que
está hablando del 94 por ciento de los
votos pero nuevamente todo puede llegar
a pasar en un escenario tan polarizado y
en un escenario tan estrecho como daban
las últimas encuestas
sofía había mucha expectativa en cuanto
al voto de los grupos indígenas unos
grupos que votaron en su mayoría a un
candidato ya q pérez que no paso se
quedó en esa primera ronda electoral
incluso señaló al cn de un supuesto
fraude porque el margen por el que las
le ganó fue muy estrecho y hubo muchos
días de incertidumbre allí en ecuador en
torno a esos resultados a quien podría
haber ido ese voto de los indígenas como
se pudo haber repartido esos grupos
indígenas en la votación
si había muchas expectativas como tú
dices del voto indígena porque después
de que ya q pérez queda descalificado de
la contienda y con todos los
cuestionamientos de fraude de pachakutik
y la conaie le apuntan a una campaña por
el voto nulo
entonces había la había la expectativa
de si el movimiento indígena y la
población indígena va a volcarse por ese
llamamiento al voto nulo y qué parte de
la que no se volcaría del voto nulo iría
para resguardados y que parte para las
con los resultados que tenemos hasta
ahora las provincias de mayor población
indígena y de mayor militancia indígena
y de articulación comunitaria con las
bases de la conaie y a ti mismo
[Música]
los núcleos de electorado de pachakutik
en la ciudad y en la amazonía le dan un
triunfo contundente a las esto estos
sorprende pero de paso ya ocurrió en el
2017 en las principales provincias con
población indígena de la tierra rey de
la amazonía le dieron el triunfo a
guillermo lasso ya en estas elecciones y
ahora se repite en elecciones anteriores
también era un poco difícil ver hacia
qué tendencia marca en estos grupos
indígenas porque no pueden ser
considerados del todo de izquierda pero
tampoco de derecha varían un poco
dependiendo de la votación julio era
difícil saber hacia dónde se iban a
dirigir estos votos después de un
llamado que hizo precisamente pérez a un
voto nulo en una especie de voto castigo
no contra los candidatos sino contra la
autoridad electoral después de esas esos
señalamientos que hubo de un posible
fraude en esa primera jornada electoral
y en esa demora que hubo para
el recuento de los votos o de las actas
de votación que le toma mucho más tiempo
de lo esperado al cn pero es difícil
ubicar a los grupos indígenas
ecuatorianos en una tendencia política
como tal cierto
en general no es tan difícil
posicionarnos en una tendencia en una
tendencia sino que en este contexto es
esta lo complicado porque es un contexto
en el que estos grupos indígenas se ven
ante una decisión de apoyar un candidato
de derecha o apoyar a un candidato que
si bien se s
se introduce como parte de la izquierda
pero ha sido contrario justamente a
varios de los intereses de estos grupos
indígenas no entonces allí ahí la
pregunta es qué pesa más una una
descripción ideológica o una una
identidad anti algo anti en este caso lo
que ha significado el correísmo los
datos porque por ejemplo en brinda sofía
son sumamente relevantes el indicar de
que en estas provincias de mayor
concentración indígena ha habido una
repetición de lo sucedido en 2017 con
cuando el voto se fue más bien tuvo más
peso la isla la identidad anti que
a la descripción ideológica como tal ya
nos da una pequeña pauta y hay una serie
de experiencias en américa latina' sobre
estas identidades anti que han marcado
al comportamiento electoral en la región
lo ha sido por ejemplo el
antifujimorismo en perú el anti machismo
en el caso boliviano el antiuribismo en
el caso colombiano que tienen al final
de cuentas terminan concentrándose en
una en un tipo de comportamiento
electoral muy similar más allá de las
diferencias ideológicas y de
heterogeneidad que puede generar este
grupo
bueno pues antes de dar paso al
siguiente tema que tenemos muchas muchas
aristas para analizar en la noche de hoy
demos un vistazo a este reportaje que
preparó la redacción de france 24
precisamente sobre la importancia del
voto indígena allí en ecuador veamos
erika arango voto con ilusión en la
primera vuelta lleva 20 años vendiendo
artesanías tradicionales en quito y
esperaba que ya q pérez ganara las
elecciones para ver a un presidente que
diera valor a su cultura indígena ahora
ya no confía en nada ella q debió de
presionar más mi sentir es que
como mujer ecuatoriana
yo estoy decepcionada de la política y
esta decepción se traducirá en las urnas
así realmente yo también voy a votar por
el nuevo tono
ese es el llamado del partido indígena
pachakutik que mantiene sus denuncias de
fraude electoral y que trata de mantener
vivo el impulso que llevó a ya q pérez a
conseguir un resultado insólito en la
primera vuelta con casi el 20 por ciento
de los votos de difundir el voto nulo de
absoluta nulidad como una protesta
social como una indignación de todo el
fraude que vivió este proceso electoral
sin embargo al contrario de su partido
el mismo ya q pérez no quiso dar ninguna
consigna concreta a sus votantes muchos
de ellos se sienten perdidos y todavía
arrastran frustración se gastó como se
suele decir popularmente lo que teníamos
y lo que no teníamos
floresmilo un dirigente indígena ve un
horizonte oscuro pero nosotros vemos el
escenario bastante bastante complejo y
difícil el cual con cualquiera de los
dos ahora el nivel de conflictividad
social va a ser casi la misma después de
un desempeño espectacular en la primera
vuelta las divisiones del voto indígena
amenazan su futuro y la oportunidad de
consolidarse como una alternativa real
en la política ecuatoriana importante
fundamental en esta segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales en ecuador
el grupo de los indígenas para definir
quién es el nuevo mandatario le dará
estabilidad política o buscará por lo
menos llegar a la estabilidad política
económica a este país suramericano por
los próximos cuatro años julio pasemos a
los candidatos importante aquí se espera
un choque de trenes aquí había dos
candidatos con dos visiones de país
completamente diferentes con dos
tendencias políticas digámoslo así
completamente diferentes en un lado
tenemos a andrés araus heredero del
correísmo partidario del socialismo del
siglo 21 para que tenga una continuidad
y en ecuador pero el mismo expresó
tendría un socialismo un poco
distanciado de lo que hizo en su momento
el ex presidente rafael correa y en el
otro lado tenemos a guillermo lasso que
representa un poco la tendencia de lo
que ya vivió ecuador un banquero cercano
a los grandes poderes económicos del
país se disputó tres veces la
presidencia de ecuador su opinión sobre
estos candidatos
como tú bien lo pones es un verdadero
choque de trenes la estación en su en su
máximo esplendor
pues de alguna manera no solamente están
las las líneas ideológicas concretas de
un lado y de otro que son muy marcadas
está también una rememoración del pasado
y el pasado inmediato y el pasado
inmediato es decir como tú vienes díaz
el pasado de posiblemente el siglo
pasado con esta lógica de presidentes en
ecuador más ligados al sector privado
principalmente a la banca y el pasado
tal vez un poco más inmediato con un
presidente muy ligado a lo que ha sido
el el correísmo durante todos los años
de gobierno
que tenía seguir la fórmula exacta para
un escenario de polarización junto con
un diseño junto con un mecanismo
institucional como esta segunda vuelta
que más bien va a promover de alguna
manera este tipo de polarización es
sofía su opinión sobre este tema usted
está allí en ecuador usted si me puede
decir desde su perspectiva qué es lo que
más le conviene a ecuador en este
momento en donde hay crisis por la
pandemia una crisis económica a raíz de
la pandemia también y después del boom
petrolero desde su perspectiva que es lo
que más le conviene ecuador
y bueno retoma un poco de la pregunta
anterior también para responder a esta
el tema de la polarización y del que
creo es lo que más le conviene al
ecuador y como como los los votos de
primera y segunda vuelta no se ha
demostrado sobre todo qué es lo que
busca el ecuador o qué es lo que de chad
entonces está en primera vuelta esa
polarización digamos yo diría que no hay
una polarización tan clara entre digamos
entre un país dividido en dos con cierto
porque se demostró un cierto que había
dos candidatos finalistas para el
segundo lugar es decir andrés dorado con
el 32% encabezó la primera vuelta y le
pidieron a guillermo lazo con el 20 por
ciento y ya q pérez pont terminó
teniendo el 19 entonces si hay un 20 por
ciento que rechazó el proyecto de
socialismo del siglo 21 lo que ya
vivimos no es cierto él es decir el
extractivismo
en los altos niveles de corrupción y el
derroche el derroche fiscal no es cierto
el mal manejo de las finanzas de en la
época de mayor bonanza de la historia
del país
y este socialismo del siglo 21 que por
un lado sigue sigue siendo un proyecto
con redes internacionales
yo diría iberoamericana porque también
españa tiene tiene importantes bases
pero ya 20 desde el ecuador desde dentro
será una oposición desde la izquierda
que logra un resultado inaudito es decir
el 20 por ciento para un candidato
propio de pachakutik propio de las bases
de la conaie quiero decir el pachakutik
es el instrumento del político de la
conaie la primera vez que un candidato
propio no en alianza con otro con otro
candidato a la presidencia lograr este
porcentaje y la primera vez que logre a
una bancada de 27 asambleístas entonces
creo que este ya es un ya es un rechazo
no es cierto aún a un proyecto del
socialismo del siglo 21 y una
interpelación
a una izquierda que realmente quedé
muerta conservadora se demuestra
autoritaria desde una izquierda que
pregona los derechos de las mujeres los
derechos de los pueblos indígenas y el
ecologismo en el ambiental y entonces yo
diría que no hay una polarización en un
país dividido en dos por esas razones y
por esa por esta demostración que nos
dieron los votantes en la primera vuelta
ahora que le combi que es la copia de
más del país y que nos están diciendo
estos votantes los pueblos indígenas o
los los movimientos sociales los
ecologistas feministas etcétera un
cierto esto estos sectores más de clase
bien de un medio urbana que adhieren al
facha cutie y que le dan ese 20% ya
cooper es porque ya q pérez no puedes
llegar al 20 por ciento si un voto
urbano y de clase media entonces está
este sector social nos está diciendo que
en esta segunda vuelta nos está diciendo
si bien pliego al voto nulo de alguna
manera por su ejemplo en acción el voto
nulo tiene más tiene el porcentaje más
alto que el apoyo a graus
es importante mencionar entonces el voto
nulo tampoco tiene un rechazo si tiene
cierta adhesión del produjo más de
adhesión a las entonces que le conviene
al país le convierte salir de este
proyecto que ya vivimos durante los 10
años del correísmo y del que no pudimos
salir por los con el último período del
digamos morenismo porque no fue un dar
un giro real de tomaron ciertas medidas
para salir de algunas de algunas
prácticas pero muchos de los
funcionarios del correísmo siguieron
permanecieron en el gobierno y sobre
todo muchas prácticas pero yo creo que
lo que le conviene al ecuador es pasar
la página y tratar de desde el congreso
esa nueva izquierda que se gestó y aquí
y bueno sumándole a la izquierda
democrática que es un partido de la
socialdemocracia ecuatoriana que había
había fallecido y que había que había
desaparecido se vuelve a la escena
entonces tratar desde él desde la
oposición en el congreso y desde las
propuestas de esta nueva izquierda e ir
hacia hacia un nuevo proyecto que
cuestione el socialismo del siglo 21 que
nos demostró en el ecuador que no dio
resultado
sofía me quedo con lo del voto nulo para
analizarlo más adelante con juli con
usted
tengámoslo ahí sobre la mesa que es un
punto importante también para destacar
julio su opinión sobre esta polarización
ya oyó la opinión de sofía que está allí
en quito la opinión en torno a esta
polarización estas dos caras de la
moneda y a estos modelos de gobierno y
lo que le puede convenir a ecuador dado
el escenario en el que se encuentra un
país endeudado con una crisis económica
desempleo la pandemia y esta segunda ola
que le está pasando por encima a todos
los países de suramérica la segunda ola
de contagio
primero aclarar aclarar un poco estoy
plenamente de acuerdo con lo que
indicaba sofía yo me refería a la
polarización más en su acepción clásica
en términos ideológicos y sobre todo
respecto de esta de esta última de esta
elección que se ha desarrollado en el
día de hoy sin embargo ella tiene toda
la razón al hacer referencia de que la
fragmentación del voto de la primera
vuelta que se ha terminado traduciendo
lo que se va a traducir eventualmente en
la conformación del legislativo
ecuatoriano si da cuenta de un escenario
no bipolar sino más bien multipolar
donde esta izquierda tanto indígena como
esta izquierda tal vez
sofía nos indicaba que ha resurgido de
alguna manera y que interpela al
socialismo el siglo 21
estaría logrando aparentemente una
importante la legislativo y no yo creo
que en un escenario delicado por la
pandemia por la situación económica en
general lo más importante en este
momento es justamente la conexión extend
entre estos dos órganos de gobierno es
decir la conexión entre la
o sea que vaya a ganar la segunda vuelta
del día de hoy con los partidos con los
representantes que hayan de alguna
manera han logrado su espacio en el
legislativo ecuatoriano es decir una
coordinación entre órganos del estado
con miras a justamente la recuperación
económica y la lucha con la pandemia
contra la pandemia que cada vez va
azotando más parecía que estábamos ya de
alguna manera al final del túnel y
volvemos nuevamente a caer en la
realidad de que esto sigue siendo un
problema para el árbol antes esa
coordinación entre órganos del estado
esa coordinación institucional con
distintos actores con una con un
parlamento bastante fragmentado donde no
hay una sola fuerza política ultra
mayoritaria y un presidente que vázquez
que es producto justamente de una
segunda vuelta
es un escenario que pone en el desafío
no solamente a ecuador sino a todos los
países latinoamericanos para poder
sobrepasar sobreponerse a la pandemia de
la crisis
bueno pues veamos entonces en detalle
quiénes son estos dos candidatos que
están disputando esa silla en el palacio
de carondelet
guillermo lasso mendoza y andrés araos
galarza comencemos entonces porque llamo
lazo un banquero que ya ha disputado la
ha intentado llegar a la presidencia de
ecuador en tres oportunidades esta sería
la tercera vez que se presenta a estos
comicios veamos de quién se trata
yo no descarto un acuerdo con ninguna
ecuatorial con ningún ecuatoriano que
actúe de buena fe que comprenda que está
por por delante un gran objetivo que
sacar adelante el país quiero entre lo
que más representa guillermo lasso es
quizás su mayor lastre en un ecuador
escéptico con los banqueros aunque
siempre reivindicó sus orígenes humildes
que le llevaron a iniciarse en el
mercado laboral con 15 años fue durante
casi 20 años presidente del banco de
guayaquil llegó a la política en 1998
como gobernador de la provincia de
guayas y al año siguiente se convirtió
en súper ministro de economía eran años
de crisis en el país andino había una
contracción de crédito y una falta de
liquidez en el sistema financiero que
ocasionó que la mayoría de sus clientes
perdieran una parte de sus ahorros
ecuador estaba hundido en el desempleo y
la inflación y en 2000 adoptó el dólar
como moneda oficial en 2013 guillermo
lasso se presentó a las elecciones
presidenciales pero perdió ante el
entonces presidente rafael correa quien
les superó por el doble de votos en 2017
laso se midió con lenin moreno el
candidato de correa
en unos comicios que terminaron en un
recuento parcial de votos tras denuncias
de fraude por parte de las conservador
cercano al opus dei es un firme opositor
al derecho al aborto y en campaña ha
tratado de convencer a los sectores
populares con la promesa de acabar con
el hambre de más de un millón de
ecuatorianos buscó solucionar el
problema de empleo promoviendo inversión
e inversión privada local internacional
en sectores estratégicos de la economía
ecuatoriana del sector público en el
sector petrolero en el sector eléctrico
en el sector de la telecomunicación
laso ha hecho campaña reivindicándose
como el gestor que puede hacer por fin
despegar la economía de ecuador de la
mano del fondo monetario internacional y
asegurando que si es presidente evitará
que ecuador se convierta en una nueva
venezuela
y esa era una cara de la moneda según el
cine guillermo lasso lleva hasta el
momento del 52 puntos 59 por ciento de
los votos de acuerdo al último reporte
del cn que publica a través de su página
web con el 96 punto 40 por ciento el 52
punto 56 por ciento el otro candidato es
andrés hará bush galarza que lleva el 47
punto 44 por ciento de los votos veamos
de quién se trata sería el abanderado
del correísmo guardando un poco de
distancia de rafael correa pero
manteniendo esas bases fundamentales del
socialismo del siglo 21 que fue
instaurado en ecuador cuando
precisamente correa llegó al poder
y la historia nuevamente habla de
nosotros es el candidato a la
presidencia de ecuador a andrés arauz y
así se define él mismo en su biografía
de 'twitter' patriota demócrata
progresista candidato a la presidencia
del ecuador nunca me niego a un cebiche
jipijapa junto con su candidato
vicepresidencial carlos abascal informan
el llamado binomio de la esperanza están
apadrinados por el ex presidente rafael
correa del que se dice que arauz va a
ser su delfín político de hecho durante
la presidencia de correa fue ministro
entre 2015 y 2017 de conocimiento y
talento humano y durante unos meses
ministro de cultura ahora pese a su
juventud a los 36 años podría
convertirse en presidente de ecuador
nosotros somos de la izquierda
progresista que está abierta a una
relación fructífera y provechosa para el
país con la socialdemocracia con la
unidad plurinacional nacido en quito
habla inglés francés y ruso y el
graduado en economía por la universidad
de michigan que define sus políticas
como posh keynesianas sociales y
solidarias
su objetivo recuperar el progresismo de
la presidencia de rafael correa una meta
que le ha llevado al consejo ejecutivo
de la internacional progresista donde
participan figuras como el senador
demócrata bernie sanders el ex ministro
de finanzas griego yannis varoufakis o
el ex vicepresidente del gobierno
español pablo iglesias unos ingleses
fuera de serie ahí está un currículum y
creo que va a ser un gran presidente del
word tras la noche de su candidatura
muchos se preguntaban quién era el
respondía que 'el perfecto desconocido'
un anonimato que no le impidió ser el
candidato más votado en la polémica
primera vuelta
cuando como iván andrés
andrés sarah o sea el otro candidato a
la presidencia de ecuador que está
disputando en la jornada de hoy es así
ya en el palacio de carondelet en quito
con sofía y con julia hemos hablado de
diferentes temas del análisis del
electorado de el voto indígena
importante allí en ecuador y quedó sobre
la mesa con sofía el tema del voto nulo
de acuerdo al registro que tiene ahora
el cn publicado hasta el momento hay un
millón 643 mil 222 votos nulos en estos
comicios que les dice a ustedes esta
cifra después de ese llamado que hizo
precisamente ya q pérez d
anular los votos comienzo entonces por
sofía y luego lo de paso a julio
bueno esta cifra es alta y nos dice que
a que los que le apostaron haya cooper
es que son casi la misma proporción que
le apostaron a guillermo lasso
tienen en común no es cierto tienen como
unos dos el rechazo al alcoholismo
tienen en común el rechazo a la forma la
práctica política del correísmo pero se
diferencian en que los alumnos sobre
todo los los que apoyan y los que
optaron por el nulo son sectores de la
población muy muy militantes o adscritos
a movimientos ya sea ya sea rurales
indígenas a lo comunitario pero también
como decía movimientos urbanos
culturales de mujeres
progresistas y ecologistas que fueron y
aquí que creo que es importante discutir
los términos del progresismo no es
cierto el progresismo está está el
progresismo internacional
la internacional progresista
tiene la capacidad de querer creer
homogeneizar los a los progresismos a
los casos de particulares o nacionales
no es cierto
timbers timberland justamente los
detalles no siento decir cómo han sido
las experiencias en cada facebook la
experiencia en el ecuador con el
socialismo del siglo 21 con el correísmo
es de un social
de una tendencia altamente conservadora
es decir no tenemos una postura
progresista respecto a derecho ni de 10
de defensa es decir de demandas de las
mujeres como legalización del aborto o
de los grupos glv son grupos que han
sido agredidos constantemente por el
correísmo por su líder no
los derechos de los pueblos indígenas lo
mismo y el tema de la ecología ambiental
entonces la agenda progresista no fue
parte del gobierno del progresismo en el
ecuador es muy paradójico no no así
digamos que yo hago siempre la
comparación con bolivia en donde ciertos
derechos es decir la agenda progresista
fue fue mucho más clara no es cierto
las prácticas digamos los liderazgos de
el movimiento del justicialismo fueron
muy variados y clientes morales tampoco
tienen una línea clara del respecto a
algunos derechos pero nada comparable
con la posición conservadora del
correcto entonces yo creo que y sobre
todo lo es qatar que por ejemplo pero el
movimiento al socialismo tiene una base
organizada una base articulada es un
partido político mientras que el
correísmo es de una fila electoral que
en las posteriores elecciones incluso se
ha quedado sin partido lo cierto y ha
ido
adaptándose a distintas siglas y no
tiene bases de electorales claras
organizadas entonces
eso sí julio su opinión sobre este voto
nulo
comparto varios de los puntos que
indicaba sofía el alta y el alto los
altos niveles de voto no lo dan nos dan
indicios de que había una respuesta al
llamado del partido y a cooper es
justamente a este a esta opción política
más en el rechazo al sistema y a las
autoridades electorales principalmente
pero sobre todo el sistema pero también
concuerdo previamente con sofía como
dice que esto es síntoma de que ese
electorado y ese movimiento político que
este estado que ha estado apoyado
justamente por ese electorado tratan de
alguna manera de diferenciarse no
solamente de la derecha de laso sino
también de esta de esta iniciativa de
este de este de estas propuestas de
izquierda que de socialismo del siglo 21
es decir tratan de buscar o tratan de
evidenciar una identidad propia al
margen de estas dos opciones políticas
ahora obviamente no es exacto y no eso
no es completamente automático y ahí
puede ser que
y sean estas clases medias a las que se
refería sofía que han apoyado también la
candidatura de ya q pérez y las que de
alguna manera han no han no han sido tan
fieles al llamado del voto nulo y han
preferido optar por una de las otras dos
fuerzas políticas
aquí hay otro tema importante que va a
tener como reto el nuevo presidente de
ecuador y es la gobernabilidad sobre
todo dada la tendencia y dado los
porcentajes de votación que les hemos
presentado pues va liderando guillermo
lasso y es quien tendría una
gobernabilidad más difícil dada la
conformación que tiene la asamblea
ecuatoriana
en las elecciones pues el correísmo
sumando todas sus fuerzas tuvo casi el
50 50 escaños de esos 137 asambleístas
que tienen allí en ecuador creo que es
el partido de lazo solamente obtuvo 12 y
su partido aliado del partido
socialcristiano tuvo 19 va a haber un
margen de acción muy muy pequeño para
ese nuevo presidente que llegue allí
dado el caso que sea guillermo lasso va
a tener muy difícil el escenario julio
esto complicaría poder hacer frente a
los verdaderos problemas que tiene
ecuador que ya vamos a pasar a hablar de
los retos que hay en materia económica
en materia social
en diversificación económica
medioambiente derechos de las minorías y
por supuesto la pandemia del cobre 19
que sería el tema transversal para toda
esta discusión
julio
efectivamente va a complicar pero yo no
yo no sería muy extremista
al irme a que va a terminar
imposibilitando la gestión es decir al
próximo presidente le va a tocar y le va
a tocar negociar le va a tocar hacer
pactos porque si bien no va a tener en
ninguno de los dos que cualquiera las
dos cada vez que darle la presidencia en
esta segunda vuelta no va a tener
mayoría tampoco está en una mira en la
minoría absoluta es decir ahorita
los datos del parlamento ecuatoriano no
dan cuenta de una mayoría clara sino que
dan cuenta de un escenario fragmentado
en el que van a tener que negociar con
las distintas fuerzas políticas y ahí
una de las claves es justamente tanto
pachakutik como la izquierda democrática
entonces en este en este escenario van a
tener que salir a hacer pactos hacer
alianzas a negociar y van a ver algunos
temas más sensibles que otros
posiblemente algunas cuestiones de
atención de la pandemia sean un poco más
sencillas
pero otras cuestiones más de carácter
social como principalmente algunas de
las demandas que sufrían nos indicaba
que son bandera de este nuevo
progresismo que está que está
reivindicando pachakuti la izquierda
democrática como por ejemplo la
despenalización del aborto que son
completamente contrarios a partir de la
nota que nos han mostrado de la o de la
opción de la preferencia política por
ejemplo y el moll asuntos van a ver
algunos temas que van a ser un poco más
más complicados van a haber otros que
van a ser un poco más sencillos pero ahí
la tendencia en o el común denominador
es la necesidad de la negociación y del
pacto del pacto político
sofía necesidad de negociación es el
punto que destacó de lo que dice julio
en este en este posible escenario que
guillermo lasso llegue a la presidencia
y se encuentra con esta asamblea tan
fragmentada en donde no tiene mayoría y
pueden obstaculizar sus políticas y el
desarrollo de su gobierno cuatro años
que pueden llegar a ser muy difíciles
sofía
si de hecho los cuatro años que se
vienen vienen difíciles para el demo
lazo guillermo lazo tiene que apostarle
a digamos a buscar apoyos a gustar
negociar con una bancada que ya está
articulada es decir ya lee acuerdos
programáticos para la acción congresal
entre el izquierdo democrática y
pachakutik digamos en firmar un acuerdo
y están en diálogos para establecer
cuáles son los puntos los puntos en
común y esta agenda y también para
tratar de buscar la presidencia y
vicepresidencia de la asamblea y
formarlas por las comisiones claves para
para organizar el manejo el
funcionamiento seguro práctico digamos
de la asamblea no entonces ahí tiene
digamos una un desafío a guillermo lazo
de establecer puentes con estos sectores
un desafío que ya bueno nosotros lo vino
el bolazo tendió cuentas en esta segunda
vuelta sino que ahora también porque
tenían que
en captar el voto de la izquierda
democrática y de diferente de pachakutik
entonces guillermo lazo tiene que
abrirse a esta agenda a esa agenda que
es progresista que progresista en temas
ambientales dependiente más de derechos
y que en la segunda vuelta demostraré de
alguna manera la capacidad de de abrirse
no es cierto ahora otra cosa es ya en la
gestión gubernamental hasta donde él
piensa en flexibilizar sus posturas
respecto a algunos temas y por otro lado
tiene la bancada la bancada del
correísmo que digamos es más digamos de
alguna bancada conservadora y lo
demostró en la gestión por cierto en la
gestación congresal en las políticas de
impulso y
si bien por ejemplo una coincidencia
entre guillermo lasso y la bancada
correcta podría hacer el desacuerdo para
la legalización del aborto sin embargo
que tenemos lazo no va a obviamente no
va a generar alianzas con el correísmo
sino que va a tener que abrirse a este
otro sector
aquí la incógnita está en la bancada
social cristiana que llega en alianza
con el partido creo de guillermo lazo
pero no sabemos ya cómo voy a actuar en
la gestión en la gestión gubernamental
es una alianza que puede que puede
permanecer como pueden no perder mar
este entonces ese es un poco el
escenario complicado en un congreso de
minoría
esa es la el partido clave para armar
este rompecabezas y darle un poco de
gobernabilidad a ese gobierno que podría
llegar eventualmente de la mano de
guillermo lasso vamos a ver unas
imágenes que nos están llegando en vivo
a la redacción de france 24 en vivo
desde ecuador son imágenes que llegan de
la campaña de andrés araujo
se espera que en cualquier momento hable
a los medios de comunicación haga algún
tipo de pronunciamiento oficial sobre
estos resultados que ha comenzado a dar
el cn después del cierre de las
votaciones a las 5 de la tarde -hora
local- hora de quito y también en unos
minutos espera que en cualquier momento
guillermo lasso también hable y por
supuesto estamos esperando algún tipo de
pronunciamiento oficial por parte del cn
que confirme ya algún tipo de resultados
ya nos decían que a las 10 de la noche a
las 22 nos decía nuestro corresponsal va
a haber un pronunciamiento oficial ahí
ven ustedes las imágenes de la campaña
de guillermo lasso en vivo y en directo
en cualquier momento va a hablar a los
ecuatorianos desde su sede de campaña en
la ciudad de guayaquil capital de la
provincia de guayas allí en la costa del
pacífico ecuatoriano escuchemos un poco
lo que se vive allí en esta sede de
campaña en guayaquil
queridos
queridos ecuatorianos
que nos acompañan
desde todo el ecuador y en el exterior
a través de los medios de comunicación y
de las redes sociales
amigos que esta noche nos acompañan aquí
un abrazo para todos
amigos de la prensa
[Aplausos]
este es un día histórico
es un día en que todos los ecuatorianos
han decidido su futuro
han expresado con su voto la necesidad
de cambio y el deseo de mejores días
para todos
[Música]
quiero
iniciar esta noche
agradeciendo en primer lugar a dios
gracias a dios por todas las bendiciones
que ha agregado sobre el pueblo
ecuatoriano
se lo debemos a él
y yo le debo a él todas las bendiciones
que me ha otorgado durante mi vida
[Aplausos]
quiero agradecer a mis padres
hace más de 40 años están en el cielo
pero solo yo sé
todo lo que les debo a ellos
que me han permitido ser lo que he sido
en mi vida
[Aplausos]
mi 1er
mi primera actividad mañana será ir con
maría de lourdes mis hijos
a depositar una ofrenda florar floral en
su tumba
[Música]
[Aplausos]
quiero agradecer a los ecuatorianos que
me han brindado su confianza
que han salido a votar con espíritu
democrático que lo han hecho en paz
y que hayan dado a nuestro país un
mensaje muy claro un mensaje contundente
los ecuatorianos creemos en la
democracia
los ecuatorianos creemos en la libertad
quiero agradecerle de manera muy
especial
a jaime nebot el líder en el partido
socialcristiano
[Aplausos]
a la diligencia nacional y provinciales
del partido socialcristiano a sus bases
por su compromiso
con este proyecto político el beneficio
del ecuador
quiero agradecerle
a mi querido hermano césar monge ortega
[Aplausos]
a la dirigencia nacional de creo a todos
los dirigentes provinciales de creo
a las bases de creo
a todos a quienes no olvidaré nunca que
me acompañaban de madrugada las
entrevistas de radio de televisión me
recibían en aeropuertos en calles y
plazas de todo el ecuador
quiero agradecerle
a mi compañero de fórmula o el
vicepresidente electo del ecuador
el doctor alfredo borrero vega
[Aplausos]
quiero agradecer
a iván correa calderón
jefe de campaña y jefe de mi equipo de
trabajo durante los últimos 11 años
y van
por dónde andas y van
iván no te escondas otra vez
[Aplausos]
i
sí
quiero
agradecer también porque justo hacerlo
a jaime durán barba y a santiago nieto
quienes me acompañaron
en esta segunda vuelta electoral
guiando estratégicamente en nuestro
camino
muchas gracias a jaime durán
y a santiago nieto
quiero agradecer a todos los líderes
políticos que sin pedir nada a cambio
nos dieron públicamente en su apoyo
[Aplausos]
quiero agradecer
a los grupos de independientes y
voluntarios que se formaron en todo el
país y que con gran trabajo llevaron
puerta a puerta el mensaje de la
democracia la libertad las oportunidades
y la prosperidad para nuestro país y
para todas las familias ecuatorianas
muchas gracias
a mi equipo de control electoral
[Aplausos]
gracias a santiago serrano
gracias a vicente al medio almeida por
es impecable el trabajo que han
realizado el día de hoy
y ahora
quiero agradecerle a la mujer de mi vida
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias a maría de lourdes
quiero agradecer
a guillermo enrique y a daiana y a sus
hijos mis nietos
[Aplausos]
quiero agradecerle
a santiago y a maría beatriz
quiero agradecerle a juan emilio y a
priscila
y a mis tres nietos los hijos de juan
emilio y priscila quiero agradecerle a
freddy mi yerno y a mi hija lole
y a mis dos nietos
la una las listas quién conocen todos
ustedes
y al nuevo nieto que llegará en el mes
de junio
quiero agradecerle a mi hija maría
mercedes
[Aplausos]
la menor de todos
y soltera
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
la verdad que estoy lleno de emoción
y la familia es el valor fundamental de
la sociedad
[Aplausos]
gracias
por formar parte del ecuador del
encuentro
gracias desde el fondo del alma desde el
fondo de mi corazón por darme la
oportunidad de ser su presidente
y poderlo servir
gracias muchas gracias
imágenes en vivo desde la ciudad de
guayaquil el puerto ecuatoriano en el
pacifico de guillermo lasso hablando a
sus seguidores y a sus colaboradores de
campaña agradeciendo por toda esta
contienda electoral de largos meses en
medio de la pandemia de kobe 19 también
a esta hora habla a sus seguidores
andrés arados pero desde la sierra desde
la ciudad de quito la capital
ecuatoriana nos conectamos en este
momento para oír lo que dicen allí el
poder popular
[Aplausos]
esta candidatura
logró de forma autocrítica y de forma
prospectiva reconstituir los vínculos
del progresismo con las organizaciones
sociales con los movimientos sociales
con las juventudes con los estudiantes
con las mujeres de la patria y nosotros
vamos a dedicarnos a seguir tejiendo
vínculos de unidad por el bienestar de
todos los ecuatorianos nosotros estamos
convencidos de que esta candidatura fue
el inicio de un proceso de
reconstrucción y reconstitución del
tejido social y productivo de nuestra
patria que ha sido desbaratada por
políticas neoliberales en estos últimos
años tenemos plena conciencia histórica
de lo que hemos logrado a lo largo de
este proceso que comenzó en agosto y
vamos a dedicarnos a la profundización
de esa construcción del tejido social y
productivo de nuestro país insisto
no es ningún final es apenas el comienzo
de una nueva etapa arduamente necesaria
para nuestro país
llegamos a esta elección en condiciones
muy complejas
todos sabemos que fuimos víctimas de la
persecución política del acoso de los
insultos del odio los intentos de
proscribir a nuestro movimiento ataques
permanentes a la persona a la familia
más que a la propuesta que estuvimos
realizando para nuestro país hace falta
una renovación real de la forma de hacer
política no solo como discurso no solo
como marketing sino con gestos reales
con gestos democráticos es muy fácil
pensar que la división solo la provoca
el otro nosotros hemos llamado a superar
el odio ya construir la nueva política
sobre la base del amor el amor al
prójimo y el amor a la patria
la hora de la democracia es la hora de
acabar con la persecución política
[Aplausos]
[Música]
señor lazo
le invito a que se respete el estado de
derecho el odio no construye vamos a
discutir democráticamente sin que sea
una amenaza para los ciudadanos sin que
se convierta en un estigma político
tener una forma de pensar tener unos
valores unos principios no queremos que
se sigan encarcelando a los ecuatorianos
por su forma de pensar
[Aplausos]
apelamos a gestos de humanidad y de
respeto a la discusión en democracia así
como nosotros estamos comprometiéndonos
hoy a poder discutir incluso airadamente
si es necesario pero respetando la
libertad y la dignidad del otro a eso
estamos abocados y eso es lo que vamos a
representar en este nuevo periodo que se
va a construir en el ecuador
el poder nunca ha sido un capricho para
mí mi única intención desde hace 15 años
ha sido siempre ser un servidor público
he puesto y seguiré poniendo mi talento
y energía al servicio de los
ecuatorianos seguiré sirviendo al pueblo
del ecuador
desde la trinchera que nos toquen desde
la trinchera que nos toque estaremos
sirviendo a nuestro pueblo construyendo
programáticamente con profundidad de
ideas formando a las siguientes
generaciones para poder llegar y llevar
a cabo procesos profundos de
transformación ese ha sido mi convicción
de toda la vida y no se detendrá el día
de hoy
es la hora de una reflexión honesta de
la autocrítica real tenía en mi mente y
en mi corazón ganar para impulsar
verdaderas políticas de transformación
de nuestro país educación de calidad
comenzando por los más pequeños por
nuestros hijos por nuestras hijas
protección y aprovechamiento de nuestra
biodiversidad
respecto a la plurinacionalidad e
interculturalidad esa deuda tan grande
que tenemos en el ecuador
el acompañamiento a las mujeres
ecuatorianas en sus luchas en sus
reivindicaciones las oportunidades para
nuestros jóvenes el alivio de las deudas
para las familias ecuatorianas
les prometo que seguiré y seguiremos
trabajando para hacer realidad todas
estas políticas y propuestas por el bien
del ecuador y de todo el pueblo
ecuatoriano
[Aplausos]
al país entero
en todo lo que parta del beneficio
colectivo del interés público del bien
común no se encontrarán listos para
dialogar conversar y trabajar como dije
antes en todo lo que esté en contra del
beneficio de las grandes mayorías no se
encontrarán trabajando duro para
evitarlo a todo el ecuador gracias por
haberme recibido en sus casas en sus
plazas
ustedes siempre cuentan conmigo espero
contar con ustedes muchísimas gracias
sandro laurent
que había la revolución ciudadana
y amigo rafael torres
pero mejor
con esto
el hasta ahora candidato de la alianza
de partidos allí en ecuador andrés araus
hablando a sus seguidores en la ciudad
de quito en ecuador la capital
ecuatoriana también veíamos unos minutos
antes a guillermo lasso hablando a sus
seguidores en la ciudad de guayaquil en
el puerto del pacífico ay hemos
presentado las dos transmisiones
simultáneas en este momento están
estaban hablando los dos al mismo tiempo
en diferentes ciudades dirigiéndose a
sus seguidores les hemos presentado las
dos caras de la moneda vamos entonces a
quitó allí está gustavo ortega en la
sede del cn en el centro de la capital
ecuatoriana hay novedades en cuanto a
los resultados hay más información allí
y gustavo adelante que es lo último
bueno tenemos un problema de audio con
gustavo vamos a arreglar esta conexión
con nuestro corresponsal permanente allí
en la ciudad de quito y estas son
imágenes en vivo que llegan desde la
ciudad de guayaquil guillermo lasso
sigue hablando a sus seguidores en la
sede de campaña hace unos minutos lo
veíamos agradecía a los diferentes
partidos que ayudaron en esta contienda
electoral que se unieron a esta a esta
formación creo que es el partido que
lidera o por lo menos que guillermo
lasso representa en esta campaña
electoral en estas elecciones que ya de
acuerdo a unos resultados preliminares
que les presentamos al principio del
programa le da una ventaja sobre andrés
araos del partido contendor ahí está
hablando a los seguidores hablando los
ecuatorianos agradeció por supuesto a su
familia a todos sus seguidores en la
tercera vez que él se presenta a unas
elecciones presidenciales en ecuador
hemos retomado entonces la conexión con
nuestro corresponsal de en quitó gustado
ahora si gustavo lo vimos fuerte y claro
adelante que es lo último allí en la
el cn en quito
321 me escucha
perfecto ha gustado adelante
si el consejo nacional electoral es
esperamos que evita los resultados
definitivos una próxima carrera nacional
pero hasta ahora conocemos que q
bueno tenemos problemas con la conexión
de gustavo allí en la sede del cn nos
estaba dando resultados parciales puedo
adelantarles algo de esta información de
acuerdo a lo que publica el cn a esta
hora en su página de internet
con el 97 punto 39 por ciento de las
actas ya escrutadas guillermo lasso
obtiene el 52 punto 52 por ciento de los
votos mientras que andrés araos obtiene
el 47 punto 48 por ciento de los votos
estos son aproximadamente unas 38 mil
940 actas de 39 mil 985 actas en total
es información que llega a esta hora
aquí a la redacción de francia 24 vamos
entonces de nuevo a guayaquil guillermo
lasso sigue hablando sigue allí y
manteniendo esta intervención escuchemos
lo que dice
[Música]
el sol
ya tengo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
que vive el ecuador
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
que no se cansen
[Música]
no quiero ni mentiras a la sala de
separadas
quiero causar que alguien te mira
y sentirme más
[Música]
guillermo lasso virtual ganador de estas
elecciones presidenciales lo confirmamos
a las 10 de la noche cuando el cnt el
parte final de esta votación por ahora
puedo decirles que él lidera con el 52
punto 52 por ciento de los votos hasta
que la autoridad electoral ecuatoriana
no confirme que él es el triunfador no
podemos mencionar y decirlo y ya
nombrarlo como presidente del ecuador
andrés araos tiene el 47 punto 48 por
ciento de los votos 97 punto 39 por
ciento de las actas escrutadas estamos
solamente unos minutos para ya recibir
un parte oficial de un informe oficial
del cn y nos permita ya darle nombre de
apellido a ese cargo a la presidencia de
ecuador
vuelvo con mis invitados sofía cordero
en la ciudad de quito y julio
ascarrunz en la ciudad de la paz sofía
comienzo con usted me llamó la atención
de esta intervención de guillermo lazo
que como ya lo decíamos va liderando en
la intención del voto
hacía mención a jaime nebot el líder del
partido socialcristiano que antes de
darle paso a la intervención del lazo
estábamos hablando de lo importante que
va a ser el partido socialcristiano en
la conformación de una posible coalición
para tener un poco más de gobernabilidad
en la asamblea pues ya teniéndolo ahí al
lado de él en estas imágenes que llegan
desde guayaquil agradeciéndole podemos
inferir que el partido socialcristiano
se va con creo
sí bueno es una es una diferencia clara
digamos el suyo atrás del cristiano
digamos el partido socialcristiano en
alianza con creo son son los que llevan
a guillermo lasso digamos a la al primer
lugar está que está a punto de obtener
no es cierto
yo me refiero más a digamos de esa
práctica me refería cuando lo mencioné
que quizás no sabemos cuál será el
comportamiento del partido
socialcristiano a esa práctica ya la
votación de algunas leyes no es cierto
digamos la representación de sectores de
grupos de interés que sí que seguramente
plegadora con pegada con creo plegada
con lazo pero tampoco es una alianza
pegada con digamos para siempre no hay
que ver hay que ver pero
sobre sobre la presencia de sobre la
presencia de jaime nebot y la
importancia del apoyo que le dio el
partido socialcristiano también hay que
mencionar que en realidad en guayaquil
el partido socialcristiano casi no le
aportó votos a negocio es decir en
guayaquil en la voz lo tuvo hubo muy una
pelea muy dura y en toda la costa en
realidad y si hubiera esperado que el
partido socialcristiano con su
maquinaria o con sus bases de su
maquinaria electoral desde mucha más
ventaja de la que le proporcionó frente
al candidato araus es decir eso es algo
eso es algo para analizar esa es una eso
es un vacío ahí que quedó no cierto un
cuestionamiento de qué pasó con lo que
se suponía que el partido
socialcristiano le daría en la costa a
guillermo las eso hay que investigar y
hay que hay que saber qué pasó sin
embargo claramente la presencia de jaime
nebot de ahí es una clara digamos es un
claro apoyo y yo diría que no podía no
ser así no tienen caso es están están
chupan están triunfando están
a punto de aceptar el triunfo no podía
ser de otra manera
pero si llama la atención dado que el
lazo tiene una presencia fuerte a nivel
político en la costa del pacífico por lo
menos en la provincia de guayas
que este partido de pronto no le hubiera
aportado tanto como se esperaba en julio
en la ciudad de la paz en bolivia retoma
algunas de las palabras que dijo andrés
arados en su intervención a sus
seguidores no ha aceptado todavía la
derrota también estamos esperando ese
momento en que hable de nuevo y frente a
sus seguidores ya sus partidarios pues
acepte una derrota pero pero ya daba
algunos algunas luces al final del túnel
le pedía guillermo lasso detener la
persecución política respetar el estado
de derecho el respeto a la diferencia de
perspectivas políticas y se mostró
abierto a trabajar en conjunto por el
bien del ecuador y reiteró que sigue
siendo un servidor público más allá de
tener o no el poder político en este
país análisis de estas palabras y esta
perspectiva andrés araus
si como bien dices no ha sido explícito
al aceptar la derrota pero si lo ha
hecho de alguna manera de manera
implícita ha asentado el terreno para lo
que es prácticamente lo que parece ser
al menos inevitable lo que es la
victoria de guillermo lasso y ya incluso
en una nota antes que ustedes mostraban
sobre el perfil de tanto a grados como
de lazo ambos han mostrado una cierta
apertura hacia hacia su contrincante de
o hacia los otros porque como bien
decíamos anteriormente no es un
escenario completamente bipolar no
solamente hay dos fuerzas políticas sino
está más bien bastante fragmentado
y ya ambos de alguna manera se abrían a
esta a esta idea de negociar de trabajar
de incluso de posibles alianzas y la
diferencia estaba en que la nota no se
estaba más en un contexto electoral en
el que posiblemente estos dos candidatos
buscaban justamente que llegara un
electorado entre indeciso y que había
votado por algunas de las otras opciones
políticas pero
ahora de alguna manera lo han ratificado
porque saben en saber al final de
cuentas de que ninguno de ellos tiene la
mayoría en el parlamento ecuatoriano al
menos no una mayoría suficiente como
para poder desarrollar sus iniciativas
sin ningún sin el apoyo de las otras
fuerzas políticas aquí se van a
necesitar unos de los otros y la duda de
estar en hasta qué punto van a llegar a
converger los partidos de lazo y dar a
bruce en ciertas temáticas como bien
decía sofía anteriormente posiblemente
en un escenario o en ciertos elementos
tal vez más en en contra desde algunos
de algunas iniciativas como por ejemplo
de estabilización del aborto y en qué
otros escenarios o en que otros y sus
van a converger con las otras fuerzas
políticas como por ejemplo para sacudido
la izquierda democrática que son las
otras las otras dos que tienen bolt que
tienen representación política bastante
interesante
bueno guillermo lasso se da
prácticamente por vencedor en estos
comicios así lo ha dicho en su
intervención ante sus seguidores y sus
copartidarios estos son algunos de los
fragmentos de esa intervención que dio
hace algunos minutos allí en guayaquil
escuchemos
gracias desde el fondo del alma desde el
fondo de mi corazón por darme la
oportunidad de ser su presidente hoy es
un día de celebración
la democracia ha triunfado
los ecuatorianos todos ustedes han usado
su derecho a elegir y han optado por un
nuevo rumbo un nuevo rumbo muy diferente
al de los últimos 14 años en ecuador
desde
[Aplausos]
el 24 de mayo próximo
asumiremos con responsabilidad
el desafío de cambiar los destinos de
nuestra patria y lograr para todos el
ecuador de oportunidades y de
prosperidad que todos anhelamos en unos
minutos tendremos los fragmentos de la
de ese discurso que dio andrés sagrados
en quitó a sus seguidores donde habla
también pues de este proceso electoral
de estas elecciones
no es muy claro en sus palabras y dice
que va a hablar con lazo asumimos que
dando un poco ahí a entender que asume
la derrota sofía igual estamos esperando
la confirmación del cn a las 10 de la
noche será esta rueda de prensa en el cn
en quito pero qué significa entonces
para ecuador que llegue el lazo con
estos retos enormes inmensos que tiene
ecuador en materia económica fuertemente
endeudado con muchísimo desempleo y con
un desafío enorme con la pandemia del
cob y 19
bueno lazo hay una evidentemente hay una
primera emoción del candidato y digamos
de todos los que apostaron por esa
opción pero la sola digamos se le viene
muy difícil no el tema el tema por
ejemplo hablando del tema de la pandemia
estamos en los grupos de países con
menor nivel de vacunación y no tenemos
un plan de vacunación no sabemos si
tenemos es decir no sabemos hacia dónde
vamos en la vacunación
hemos tenido vamos por el quinto
ministro de salud y dicen no hay quinto
malo es un chiste de la última semana es
decir el día una es una crisis de
gobernabilidad llamémoslo así pero de
institucionalidad agudísima que no hemos
visto en ningún ningún momento no sólo
la pandemia es es única no es cierto
ningún país ha enfrentado una pandemia
pero aparte la crisis de instituciones y
de manejo de lo público que estamos
viviendo el ecuador no ha vivido algo
parecido creo que nunca no entonces
empezar por el tema de vacunación además
el candidato ha ofrecido en los primeros
100 días
vacunar digamos a una gran cantidad de
personas habrá que ver cómo va a salir
de aquello cómo va a enfrentar esto qué
plan tiene el candidato a vicepresidente
es eso un médico
y ha dado una gira justo en la última
semana buscando buscando parece cómo
conseguir una vacuna y cómo establecer
ese plan habrá que ver no y por el tema
económico yo creo que la apuesta será
obviamente a los multilaterales es decir
la el apoyo debe de países del fondo
monetario que es la línea que ya venía
el gobierno anterior pero reforzar esa
línea y bueno habrá que ver cuáles son
las políticas del interno no cómo
enfrentar el desempleo cómo enfrentar el
empobrecimiento y si se viene muy bien
julio antes de darle paso a su
intervención quiero que escuchemos
algunos de los fragmentos un fragmento
de la intervención de andrés araus ante
sus seguidores allí en quitó escuchemos
este es un traspié electoral pero de
ninguna manera es una derrota política
ni moral
luego de estas declaraciones de prensa
realizaré una llamada telefónica al
señor guillermo lasso le le felicitaré
por el triunfo electoral obtenido el día
de hoy
y le demostraré nuestras convicciones
democráticas de poder seguir aportando
al desarrollo del país cuando se trate
de beneficiar a la mayoría de nuestra
gente y de oponernos constructiva y
responsablemente cuando se busque
simplemente atender a privilegios
andrés sagrados hace unos minutos en la
ciudad de quito hablando ya de este
virtual triunfo de guillermo lasso como
presidente de ecuador en estas
elecciones en unos minutos habrá una
rueda de prensa en cn para confirmar
estos resultados julio
me pasa el dato internamente mi editor
ángela gutiérrez me dice que de acuerdo
a estas palabras que ha dicho andrew
zarautz rompe con una mala tradición que
había en ecuador que siempre el
candidato que quedaba en la segunda
posición
así acusaciones de fraude a que vemos un
diálogo un poco más diplomático más
conciliador abierto a trabajar con lazo
a que se respete las diferencias en los
puntos de perspectiva político reconoció
que ha triunfado incluso rafael correa
ya a través de su cuenta en twitter
el triunfo de guillermo lasso y esto
puede ser un primer paso para acercar
extremos terminar la polarización
unificar y avanzar juntos
posiblemente pero más que todo es un
primer paso para la reconstrucción
institucional de la que sofía que
claramente pedía prácticamente porque es
es necesaria una reconstrucción y una
modificación institucional no solamente
negocio sino en todos los países que han
pasado por ciertos procesos de
desinstitucionalización política y en
especial democrática entonces este este
cambio está esta nueva forma de encarar
la política al final termina
favoreciendo más a la democracia que al
propio ahora búsqueda lazo o que a
cualquier otra fuerza política y es
necesario esto es necesario justamente
una reconstrucción y una solidificación
de la democracia de las instituciones
democráticas pero también de las
prácticas y las actitudes democráticas
a veces prestamos mucha atención porque
es absolutamente necesario a las
instituciones formales especialmente
como la como la única respuesta son son
absolutamente necesarias pero también
son importantes estos elementos
discursivos estos elementos
actitudinales porque de alguna manera
terminan
cuando tenía permeando en la ciudadanía
y evitan posiblemente disturbios evitan
conflictos no solamente esta noche no
solamente las de hasta hasta que se
posesione las nuevas autoridades sino
con él una vez que inicie el nuevo
gobierno y una vez que entendiendo no
solamente por gobierno al ejecutivo sino
también al legislativo y una vez que se
empiece que se tengan que remangar las
mangas y ponerse a trabajar para
justamente cubrir los desafíos que ha
dejado principalmente la pandemia retos
muy grandes los que tiene el nuevo
presidente de ecuador vamos a la sede
del cn en quito- gustavo ortega tiene
allí información adicional vamos a ver
si ya tenemos la conexión establecida
con nuestro corresponsal así en la
ciudad de quito gustado buenas noches
muy atentos al reporte que usted nos
tiene desde allí adelante
sí muy buena noche para ti pero a esta
hora con el 97 como 60 por ciento de los
votos escrutados el 52 51 por ciento de
los votos favorecen al candidato
guillermo lazos mientras que el 47 49
por ciento de los votos contabilizados a
favor de andrés araujo por el cual en
cualquier momento se producirá una nueva
cadena en nacional ya podemos escuchar
al fondo cómo se produce la presentación
pudiera suceder la entrada de los
consejeros de este órgano comicial dado
que inclusive estaríamos hablando de que
guillermo la socialidad el virtual el
presidente del ecuador como dato
importante es que sería la cuarta
ocasión que un presidente un candidato
en segunda vuelta como en segundo lugar
retrata a los resultados y se hace con
la presidencia de este país así que
estamos esperando la entrada de
cualquier minuto del consejo nacional
electoral ya vimos como los consejeros
del órgano comicial producen su
pronunciamiento si gustavo gracias pues
no muy lejos de allí donde usted está ya
ha comenzado esta rueda de prensa nos
conectamos entonces con la
que llega desde esa sede del cn
escuchamos a las autoridades electorales
que nos acompañan en este reporte
magíster diana atamaint presidenta del
consejo nacional electoral ingeniero
enrique pita garcía vicepresidente
magíster 'josé cabrera' zurita consejero
doctor luis verdesoto consejero
ingeniera stella acero consejera en este
momento damos la palabra al
vicepresidente ingeniero enrique pita
garcía
señora presidente del consejo nacional
electoral compañeros consejeros
señores observadores
amigos de la prensa
público en general acá presente
en calidad de vicepresidente del consejo
nacional electoral debe expresar mi
absoluta satisfacción por esta jornada
cumplida
en la cual
hemos podido demostrar que la eficiencia
en la capacidad la dedicación la
interesa que hemos puesto
para
que la voluntad popular se respete se ha
manifestado con una participación masiva
de ecuatorianos y por supuesto con el
respeto absoluto a la voluntad popular
no puedo dejar de mencionar el
agradecimiento a cerca de 40.000
funcionarios de este consejo nacional
electoral que con su trabajo denodado
sacrificado en épocas difíciles
arriesgando su vida incluso y algunos si
las sacrificaron
han contribuido a llegar a este punto de
gran satisfacción para nosotros
hemos dado claras muestras de eficiencia
responsabilidad y transparencia se ha
respetado la voluntad popular
pero quiero también enfatizar en que
esta jornada no es en nada diferente a
la jornada de la primera vuelta
electoral
la diferencia está en las sombras que se
levantaron respecto a ese evento por
sectores que buscaron desprestigiar
nuestra gestión con fines políticos
hoy con satisfacción podemos dar a la
ciudadanía
la respuesta que ellos esperaban un
consejo nacional electoral transparente
eficiente
agradezco a mis compañeros del consejo
nacional electoral a mis compañeros
consejeros
a ustedes señores de la prensa a ustedes
señores observadores por haber
participado activamente en la jornada de
hoy día y haber podido atestiguar esto
que a mi criterio nos debe satisfacer
muchísimo hemos cumplido con la
democracia de este país
hemos actuado con responsabilidad
y hemos podido entregarle a la
ciudadanía
la voluntad que ellos querían de quienes
han deseado que sean sus próximas
autoridades nacionales esa es nuestra
satisfacción muchas gracias a ustedes
gracias vicepresidente damos paso en
este momento al magíster 'josé cabrera'
zurita consejero del cn
gracias buenas noches con todos sobre
las noches señora presidenta señorita
consejera compañeros consejeros
un saludo mi agradecimiento a la prensa
nacional y extranjera a los observadores
extranjeros y nacionales que arriesgando
su salud sus vidas están aquí
siendo testigos
del respeto a la democracia en el
ecuador
existía otros procesos electorales' hoy
en otros países pero dieron la debida
importancia al proceso electoral en el
ecuador gracias por su presencia
mi agradecimiento especial a los
compañeros del consejo nacional del
electoral
por ese sacrificio arduo
y sacrificando incluso no solo la parte
personal se incluye sino también de las
familias de sus familias recordamos a
los compañeros que ya no están con
nosotros
que hoy
dios les llevo
cumpliendo su trabajo cumpliendo su
labor hasta el último día
demostramos que a pesar de la crisis
financiera
el proceso electoral contó con
tecnología de punta se acabaron las
fallas informáticas
se acabaron los famosos apagones nunca
más en un proceso electoral puede haber
estos temas los técnicos nacionales si
somos capaces somos honrados
somos buenas personas
y somos profesionales a kant a caballo
insisto a pesar de una situación
financiera complicada en medio de una
pandemia lo hicimos bien mi
agradecimiento a todos esos técnicos
que demostraron la capacidad que tiene
nuestro objetivo era la democracia del
país y ahora le hemos cumplido
respetando la decisión de cada uno de
los ecuatorianos
nuestro único derrotero
y nuestro único
plan fue respetar el código de la
democracia la constitución de la
república del ecuador
tanto el escrutinio realizado por los
miembros de las juntas receptoras del
voto que fueron capacitados por el
consejo nacional electoral como el
óptimo funcionamiento de nuestro sistema
informático leandra garantizaron un
proceso ágil que ratifica nuestra
capacidad
altamente técnica para darle certezas al
país sobre la jornada democrática que el
día de hoy la llevamos
gracias a todo el país que acudió
cívicamente a ejercer su derecho del
voto para escoger al mandatario que el
pueblo seleccionó nadie más
gracias a todo el país una difícil
situación de pandemia pero ahí estuvimos
y ahí estaremos gracias señora
presidenta
gracias consiguieron cabrera continuamos
con el doctor luis verdesoto consejero
del consejo nacional electoral
amigos hoy es un día importante para la
democracia ecuatoriana a pesar de la
pandemia los ciudadanos ecuatorianos
hemos votado con orden y con
tranquilidad salvo casos residuales el
proceso ha transcurrido en normalidad
agradezco a todos personal del cine a
las fuerzas armadas a la policía a los
partidos políticos y espero sobre todo a
la ciudadanía ecuatoriana por su aporte
la democracia este proceso no ha
concluido
tenemos que escrutar cuidadosamente los
votos y que se superen los recursos
jurídicos de haberlos
los datos oficiales serán los únicos que
expresan la voluntad del pueblo
ecuatoriano
hace minutos he escuchado a dos
ecuatorianos que fueron candidatos hasta
el día de hoy que se han expresado y han
expresado a la patria cada uno desde su
punto de vista ahora la tarea de todos
es reconstruir la nación de ver qué
elementos compartimos y tener claro los
elementos comunes que tenemos como
objetivos de la nación la tarea
fundamental del ecuador ahora es
reconstituir a su sistema político y
expresado y he visto hoy día expresiones
sintomáticas de que podremos hacerlo de
que la crisis de la política de la buena
política ecuatoriana puede tener un
cauce para resolverse yo creo que ahora
es un día importante para la democracia
ecuatoriano como cuando inicie esta
estas palabras porque creo que hemos
comenzado en la ruta de crear un sistema
político plural y aquello es sumamente
importante en la reconstrucción en la
terminar la transición ecuatoriana la
transición hacia un proceso democrático
un proceso democrático plural un proceso
democrático de múltiples partidos de
múltiples actores de múltiples agentes
que nos permita superar el miedo que nos
ha dejado la pandemia que nos permita
superar el hambre que nos permita tener
claro que la democracia es el mejor y es
el único ambiente para tener nuevos
proyectos de desarrollo que ahora en
este proceso hemos dicho un control de
daños de la pandemia sobre la calidad
democrática y hemos salido bien hemos
salido adelante sabemos que está dañado
y que ha funcionado bien yo creo que en
nuestras manos me refiero a la de todos
los ecuatorianos en este rato está
reconstruir este proceso este proceso de
saber hacia dónde vamos cómo superamos
los daños que nos ha dejado la pandemia
que nos ha dejado un proceso de
desarrollo en los términos en que está
en qué y cómo redefinimos las nuevas
formas de la justicia de la igualdad y
fundamentalmente de la pluralidad
creo que el día de hoy los ecuatorianos
hemos dado una muestra de que podemos
hacerlo de que vamos a hacerlo y que los
ecuatorianos todos desde todos los
ámbitos construiremos reconstruiremos
fortaleceremos crearemos aquello que
constituye el objetivo de la nación la
justicia la igualdad la paz la
pluralidad
muchas gracias doctor verdesoto ahora
nos acompaña la ingeniera stella ha sido
consejera del cn
muy buenas noches con todos y todas los
y las ecuatorianas y ecuatorianos
estimada presidenta colegas consejeros
tenemos que felicitar al pueblo
ecuatoriano por haber acudido a las
urnas de forma pacífica
por haber acudido a las urnas respetando
los protocolos de bioseguridad también
tenemos que reconocer a todos los
funcionarios del consejo nacional
electoral
a todos y cada uno de los miembros de
las juntas receptoras del voto que en su
mayoría son estudiantes universitarios
hoy nos han dado la muestra los jóvenes
los estudiantes de nuestro país de que
se puede trabajar con eficiencia
eficacia y transparencia que cuando nos
comprometemos nos comprometemos de
corazón esa es la mejor muestra que nos
han dado y muchas gracias gracias por
ese trabajo por la patria por todos los
y las ecuatorianas y ecuatorianos
felicitamos también a las organizaciones
políticas tenemos que reconocer y
felicitar el acompañamiento de las
organizaciones internacionales de los
observadores nacionales que nos han
acompañado en esta jornada de elecciones
nosotros nuestro compromiso de seguir
trabajando para profundizar la
democracia respetando la constitución
respetando la ley y esta es la mejor
muestra de que cuando se hace un trabajo
eficiente cuando se hace un trabajo
apegado a la ley cuando se hace un
trabajo honesto y con ética nada falla
tenemos que reconocer a nuestros colegas
consejeros
a todos quienes trabajan en el consejo
nacional electoral y a todos aquellos
que han arrimado el hombro para que este
proceso salga de la mejor manera salga
transparente como se merece el pueblo
ecuatoriano porque el pueblo ecuatoriano
se merece tener autoridades con ética se
merece tener autoridades honestas se
merece tener autoridades que den
respuestas como lo hemos hecho hoy
gracias a todos y todas
gracias con se gira a 0 a continuación
damos la palabra a la magíster diana
atamaint presidente del consejo nacional
electoral
muchas gracias muy buenas noches
estimados consejeros estimada consejera
pueblo ecuatoriano
hoy en las urnas las ecuatorianas y los
ecuatorianos hemos dado señales muy
claras para que los actores políticos y
sociales y nuestros gobernantes tengan
siempre presente que somos un pueblo
pensante alegre y decidido y que ama al
ecuador y sobre todo que quiere vivir en
democracia en un país incluyente
tras esta jornada cívica alegre y
pacífica y una vez que se ha cumplido
con el escrutinio en el país a esta hora
se ha procesado
un porcentaje mayor al 97% de las actas
de resultados
es así que el pleno del consejo nacional
electoral se instalará en audiencia
pública de escrutinios hasta este
miércoles para conocer los resultados
así como los recursos que tienen derecho
a interponer las organizaciones
políticas y cumplir finalmente con la
proclamación de resultados de presidente
y vicepresidente de la república del
ecuador-
así juntos de la mano transitaremos los
próximos años por el camino que nos
lleve a consolidar la democracia y a
superar la profunda crisis sanitaria y
económica provocada por la cob y 19
durante la preparación de la segunda
vuelta y en el transcurso de esta
jornada se ha informado a la ciudadanía
minuto a minuto sobre el desarrollo de
la misma
de manera ágil y oportuna se ha conocido
el avance del escrutinio a nivel de
provincias y de todo el país
ha operado sin falla ni interrupción el
sistema informático de escrutinios y
resultados
y lo ratifico esta noche los apagones
informáticos quedaron en el pasado
y aparte alguien me preguntaba en redes
sociales
si el cn había pagado la cuenta de la
luz pagamos también la cuenta de la
energía eléctrica no hubo apagaron es
los señalados nos no son sino pequeñas
muestras pero contundentes que dejan
desvanecidas y sin piso las campañas
orquestadas en contra de las personas y
las instituciones que integramos la
función electoral
este momento sin precedentes en la
historia electoral del ecuador
caracterizado por la alta participación
ciudadana por la organización y
realización impecables de las votaciones
por el funcionamiento eficiente de los
sistemas de información por la
participación comprometida de los
miembros de las juntas receptoras del
voto por el acompañamiento de la policía
y las fuerzas armadas por la presencia
de observadores internacionales y
nacionales por la participación de
decenas de miles de delegados de khan de
los candidatos finalistas y sobre todo
por la transparencia garantizada por
quienes integramos el consejo nacional
electoral se constituye un ejemplo que
sin duda será emulada por otros países
de américa latina y el mundo
hemos cumplido con el país hemos
cumplido con la democracia y aquí
estamos de pie con la frente en alto
diciéndole a nuestro país que actuamos
con transparencia como somos todos los
ecuatorianos de corazón limpio y que
amamos al ecuador que vive el ecuador
que viva la democracia buenas noches
gracias presidenta por favor en rueda de
prensa del cn en la ciudad de quito en
ecuador estamos esperando alguna o algún
pronunciamiento oficial que diera ya el
nombre el apellido el porcentaje el
ganador de estas elecciones
presidenciales en ecuador
seguimos entonces mencionando que el
virtual ganador sigue siendo hasta el
momento guillermo lasso vamos entonces
hasta la sede del cn allí en quitó está
gustavo ortega para conocer más detalles
resumir un poco lo que han dicho estas
autoridades electorales varios anuncios
importantes gustavo han dicho y no
tenemos todavía oficialmente un ganador
por lo menos por parte del cn oficial no
hay
si tal y como tú lo dices por un momento
lo que podemos anunciar que con el 97 91
por ciento de las actas escrutadas
guillermo la social virtual el
presidente con el 52 como a 49 por
ciento y andrés schaer a 2 ponga el 47
51 por ciento el anuncio en todo caso de
la noche es que el pleno del consejo
nacional electoral se ha instalado en
audiencia pública en nacional todo esto
para resolver así los recursos que bien
los candidatos vayan a presentar ante el
tribunal contencioso electoral y será
hasta el día miércoles cuando el consejo
nacional electoral declarar los
resultados definitivos de presidente y
vicepresidente otra de las declaraciones
que insistió la presidenta alcanzó
nacional electoral y el ingeniero
consejero josé que de veras es se
acabaron los apagones se ha acabado
el crisis del sistema informático y se
ha superado de esta manera las continuas
fallas informáticas que sucedían a la
hora de emitir los resultados por parte
del consejo nacional electoral como ya
podemos observarlo y escuchar ya se ha
pronunciado los distintos candidatos
guillermo la sosería del virtual
presidente de la república no podemos
dar el nombre específico de hasta que el
órgano comicial no lo declaró el
presidente pero en reacción a este
discurso que ofreciera hace un par de
minutos básicamente se pronunció para
agradecer así a su equipo de trabajo y
el candidato andrés grau básicamente ha
dicho no es el final esto apenas es un
traspié electoral e inclusive ha dicho
que llamará al candidato guillermo lazo
virtual presidente de la república para
felicitarlo con los resultados
electorales y le ha hecho algunas
demandas inclusive a guillermo las
básicamente exigió un cambio en la forma
de hacer política ha dicho que debe
acabarse la verificación política de
igual forma también el candidato andrés
ahora os invita al respeto al estado de
derecho y de igual forma a crear un
diálogo éste podría ser el virtual
escenario hay que destacar que en la
asamblea nacional no habrán mayorías y
por el cual inclusive para él el virtual
presidente guillermo lasso será un reto
gobernar inclusive en la asamblea
nacional porque la primera fuerza
parlamentaria es inclusive la que
favorece a la corriente corre y está la
segunda fuerza parlamentaria sería el
movimiento indígena e inclusive la
tercera vuelta
la fuerza parlamentaria sería la que
forma el partido político creo y luego
izquierda democrática que sería la
cuarta fuerza parlamentaria pero está la
izquierda democrática ha afirmado de
lucybell un pacto de gobierno con el
movimiento pachakutik la fuerza política
que agrupa los movimientos indígenas así
que estaríamos esperando un
y suerte de cabildeo muy fuerte para
poder así mantener adelante e impulsar
los proyectos políticos desde la
asamblea nacional y luego que guillermo
lasso se declarase a declarar como
virtual presidente gustavo gracias por
esta conclusión cierre de este bloque de
análisis y de transmisión del
cubrimiento de la elección presidencial
allí en ecuador muchas gracias por todos
estos reportes desde el cn y pues
entonces a la espera a gustavo hasta el
miércoles tendremos el pronunciamiento
oficial por parte del cn o antes si este
grupo que se reúne que se declaró ya en
reunión permanente para hacer el
recuento de los votos pues lo determina
así y da a conocer un resultado en unos
cuantos días antes le quiero agradecer
también a sofía cordero ya julio
ascarrunz en equipo y en la paz que
estuvieron con nosotros a lo largo de
esta transmisión especial para analizar
para todos ustedes diferentes puntos de
vista de estas elecciones en ecuador
y ahora doy paso entonces a algunos de
los pronunciamientos que han dado
algunos de los presidentes de américa
latina- que pese a que todavía no hay un
resultado oficial por parte de las
autoridades electorales de ecuador ya
los resultados pues dan a un virtual
ganador y es guillermo lasso y uno de
los primeros en pronunciarse es luis
lacalle pou presidente de la república
oriental del uruguay dice a través de su
cuenta de twitter acabo de hablar con
guillermo lasso para felicitarlo por su
triunfo y para ponernos a trabajar en
conjunto en los temas que tengamos en
común en nuestros países también el
pronunciamiento por parte del presidente
iván duque de colombia país vecino con
el que ecuador tiene una relación
estrecha una relación histórica sobra
decirlo y también hay un reconocimiento
por parte de juan guaidó que es el
presidente de venezuela reconocido por
50 países alrededor del mundo así otros
mandatarios de la región han comenzado a
dar su felicitación a guillermo lasso y
se han mostrado ya abiertos a trabajar
con ecuador- para hacer frente a la
pandemia con 19 temas económicos y temas
políticos pues hasta el miércoles
tendremos entonces
resultados pasamos ahora entonces
analizar la situación que se está
presentando en perú allí también hubo
comicios como se los habíamos dicho al
inicio del programa
para esta segunda parte del programa
hemos invitado a erika brockmann quiroga
jazz exparlamentaria y politóloga es
boliviana se encuentra en la ciudad de
la paz en bolivia va a estar con
nosotros analizando la situación
política que hay en perú y también vamos
a analizar la situación en bolivia otro
país que también estaba en jornada
electoral regional el día de hoy y está
con nosotros también desde la ciudad de
lima la capital peruana enzo helguera él
es analista de opinión pública marketing
político marketing e investigador de
mercados es si yo de la encuestadora y
más solo como ya lo decía se encuentra
allí en la ciudad del email por supuesto
está con nosotros nuestro corresponsal
francisco zacarías a quién voy a
conectar en este momento para que nos dé
una mirada rápida de lo que ha sucedido
allí en lima si hay avances en el
recuento de los votos a las 7 de la
noche hora de perú cerraron las urnas y
el conteo avanza lento pero como se
espera en francisco lento pero seguro
cuál es el reporte está ahora francisco
así santiago tal como se lo he hecho el
conteo avanza lento pero seguro hemos
conversado con algunos funcionarios de
la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales nos han indicado que están
procesando las actas hay algunos
personeros de algunas agrupaciones
políticas quienes han tachado algunas
actas esto va a llevarle luego este a
una discusión interna en el jurado mismo
y van a seguir procesados de una vez que
éstas sean absueltas la proyección es
que a las 11 y 30 de la noche recién se
van a conocer los resultados oficiales
conforme vaya avanzando este conteo de
votos lo que hace el momento se tiene es
los resultados a boca de urna y ellos se
están desplegando mejor dicho están
dando a conocer por ahora que lo que se
va a producir es un congreso fragmentado
esta jornada electoral se ha elegido aún
el presidente y ha puesto una nómina de
virtuales digamos candidatos que tienen
posibilidades de pasar tanto a la
segunda vuelta pero se está también
perfilando un nuevo congreso de 130
legisladores este congreso señalan que
va a ser fragmentado porque digamos que
podrían estar presentes entre 6 y 7
agrupaciones políticas pero no va a
haber una supremacía no va a haber una
mayoría sino que se van a producirse
diversas bancadas y esto según los
expertos va a poner al nuevo presidente
o presidenta del perú toda vez que no
hay resultados oficiales va a poner una
situación delicada porque se va a dar el
caso de que el nuevo presidente de perú
tenga que negociar con los
parlamentarios y hacer consensos para
implementar políticas de gobierno y en
toda vez que se repetiría mención a una
situación en la cual habría un confort
entre un poder legislativo y el
parlamento y en cualquier momento podría
producirse una situación de impeachment
o vacancia presidencial cuando lo
considere necesario
gracias a francisco por este reporte
desde la ciudad de lima esperamos
resultados a partir de las once y media
de la noche hora de lima darán a conocer
un avance del recuento de los votos
francisco ya lo mencionaba un parlamento
un congreso en perú completamente
fragmentado
la crisis política en ecuador en perdón
en perú es completamente algo que se
sale de los estándares que ha tenido
este país con una joven democracia
cuatro presidentes en cuatro años y
sobre todo una desconfianza por parte de
los ciudadanos hacia la clase política y
hacia las instituciones veamos este
reportaje que ha preparado la redacción
de france 24 precisamente sobre ese
congreso fragmentado
seis candidatos se disputan dos puestos
para una prácticamente segura segunda
vuelta electoral los sondeos sitúan en
cabeza a yonhy lescano del
centroizquierda acción popular es el
único que superaría ligeramente el 10
por ciento de voto forma parte del
partido de manuel merino uno de los
cuatro presidentes que ha tenido perú en
los últimos cuatro años su período fue
de ciento días pensamos que esta
economía hacia una economía liberal sin
límite sin sensibilidad muy cerca de
sigue a hernando de soto de avanza país
economista de derecha con experiencia
internacional ha conseguido un aumento
en la intención de voto en las últimas
semanas porque es una persona un
profesional que ha ayudado a muchos
países a desarrollarse yo creo que no
puede apoyar a nosotros los peruanos
desde un país grande también ha estado
creciendo en los sondeos verónica
mendoza de la coalición de izquierda
juntos por perú quien busca que el país
forme parte de una nueva izquierda
latinoamericana
toda la gente que ustedes ven aquí no
está apagada nuestra financiada por
grandes alrededores
auto considerado de centro se encuentra
georges forsythe del partido victoria
nacional así se presenta hijo un padre
diplomático por lo cual le creció en
muchos países también jugador de fútbol
profesional ex seleccionado del perú
también tiene posibilidades una
candidata conocida keiko fujimori del
derechista fuerza popular es la
representante del fujimorismo iniciado
por su padre el ex presidente alberto
fujimori ha estado tres veces en prisión
preventiva acusada de corrupción
nosotros lo que hablamos es de trabajar
para recuperar la vida y la salud la
vida y la economía de todos los peruanos
más descolgado en las encuestas está el
ultraderechista rafael lópez aliaga
cercano al opus dei por quedar muy
tranquilo mi casa pero me convierte
pleito por el bien de perú pero no va a
hacer desvela sobre mi cadáver la
corrupción la pobreza y la falta de
representatividad son señaladas como las
causas del que es quizá el principal
rasgo de esta elección el desinterés de
los votantes
muchos candidatos en esta primera ronda
de elecciones allí en perú
erika brockman allí en la ciudad de la
paz en bolivia país vecino que también
están jornada electoral
erika que nos puede decir esta
atomización de candidatos 18 aspirantes
a la presidencia 6 fórmulas que pueden
llegar a esta segunda vuelta que es lo
que indica esto en el escenario político
peruana
bueno muy buenas noches en primer lugar
y muchas gracias santiago un saludo a
francia y agradecimiento por france 24
bueno pero hace mucho tiempo está
atravesando un problema muy serio de
fragmentación y además el fenómeno de
una democracia compartidos tremendamente
volátiles y con una inestabilidad
crónica que da cuenta de el desgaste del
sistema político y la gran dificultad de
instalarse fuerzas políticas que
respondan una mediación en la
representación de los peruanos
en realidad la fragmentación da cuenta
también de una novia hay una
desconfianza absoluta en todas las
instituciones sin embargo lo curioso es
de que pareciera que en perú de alguna
manera se ha separado la dinámica de la
economía de la política porque en
términos económicos ha tenido relativa
autonomía su funcionamiento y no tan
sensible a las turbulencias políticas y
a los vacíos políticos que se han tenido
que experimentar especialmente por la
huella y los antecedentes de corrupción
que han manchado la trayectoria de
varios políticos que han tenido
inclusive una una presencia histórica el
caso de alan garcía es emblemático si en
su opinión sobre esta volatilidad está
que llama mucho la atención esta
cantidad de candidatos que hay y esta
desconfianza que hay por parte de los
ciudadanos peruanos hacia la institución
electoral hacia la política y hacia los
candidatos y también lo mencionaba a
erika hacia unos partidos que también se
están dispersando no hay un partido
completamente fuerte o afianzado que
esté allí tomando un liderazgo
bueno en principio aqui en peru las
elecciones son más
de más atípicas en el contexto de que
tenemos un candidato presidencial y la
cual la mayor parte de estas elecciones
para entender mejor el contexto está
basada en la figura pública del
candidato político es por ello que el
candidato puede crear un partido
político o si no le alcanza cumplir
aquellos requisitos que le ponen las
normativas electorales entonces adquiere
un partido político o es invitado a un
partido político con relativa facilidad
hasta el momento de esas situaciones se
han estado dando los partidos políticos
o las instituciones en perú
lamentablemente se han convertido en
vehículos para llegar al poder y muchas
veces después de esa transición incluso
llegando al poder son abandonados ha
pasado con presidentes electos que han
gobernado sin su propia bancada
aliándose incluso con otras bancadas de
otros partidos políticos esto nos da
cuenta que
la institucionalidad que deberían
representar los partidos políticos no se
ve claramente representada hay una
debilidad de los partidos políticos del
sistema político y evidentemente está
tratando la normativa electoral de
siempre tener requisitos que puedan
ajustar y hacer compleja la inscripción
de nuevos partidos políticos de hecho en
la actualidad por ejemplo muchos de
estos partidos políticos que se han
presentado van a perder su inscripción y
tendrían que cumplir con requisitos muy
serios si es que vuelven a tener la
oportunidad de poder participar
nuevamente en elecciones entonces aquí
la dicotomía entre candidato y partido
político la debilidad que también
representa
erika algo que llama la atención en
estas tres selecciones que tienen en
común estos tres países ecuador perú y
bolivia es la polarización la
radicalización de la sociedad y una
falta de confianza en el sistema
esto se puede tomar no solamente como un
síntoma particular de estos países sino
un síntoma general que se está empezando
a presentar en américa latina por el
mismo escenario en el que están los
países el agotamiento por la pandemia de
kobe 19 la caída económica en la mayoría
de los países y sobre todo gobiernos que
no han sido capaces de manejar esta
coyuntura que no es una coyuntura de la
región sino mundial
bueno tienes plenamente la razón al
señalar que el el cob y la pandemia ha
cobrado una factura muy alta a los
gobiernos que han tenido que
administrarla en todo caso el problema
político y la fragmentación esta suerte
de falta de afecto hacia el compromiso
político y hacia una sigla política por
parte de la población es un fenómeno
generalizado y que progresivamente se ha
instalado desde hace mucho tiempo en
nuestros países el caso de bolivia sería
la excepción en el sentido de que existe
si un partido predominante que ha ganado
es el caso del movimiento al socialismo
único que tiene presencia en todos el
territorio nacional y que tiene al
frente una constelación una constelación
de partidos también fragmentados y que
ha experimentado el mismo fenómeno de
los candidatos buscando siglas porque no
tenían partido y las siglas buscando
candidatos pero lo más grave es que la
normativa
y ahora en bolivia y para las
organizaciones políticas presenta
grandes retos y desafíos porque se
supone que este año y hasta el próximo
año tiene que renovarse y actualizarse
las bases de militantes y hoy día
estamos sufriendo lo que se llama
también el síndrome de los partidos sin
militancia a excepción del más que tiene
una militancia heroica épica identitaria
o también prebendal izada y corporativa
el el bloque social anti más anti
movimientos al socialismo es
profundamente anti partidista
eligen otros caminos para hacer
manifestarse políticamente sin embargo
hoy día en las elecciones que cerramos
el ciclo histórico más largo conflictivo
y accidentado que hemos tenido a lo
largo de la historia democrática hoy día
que cerramos esto nos damos cuenta que
empezamos a dar la vuelta a la página y
tenemos que mirar todas las señales que
nos está dando la población a través de
su voto en esta segunda
vuelta de las sub nacionales
en su en la ciudad de lima a sus
impresiones sobre sobre esta
polarización esta radicalización que
también pero no es capaz de eso sobre
todo la polarización y que ha llevado
creo que también es un síntoma de esta
atomización que es el tema con el que
empezamos el debate
la polarización que ha ocurrido aquí
está evidentemente como una manera de
contestar básicamente al modelo y al
sistema económico que por un lado ha
fallado en la administración de la
pandemia y en la propia reactivación
económica la sensibilidad política o la
falta de ella en relación a los sectores
y segmentos más pobres de la población
han dejado mucho que desear respecto de
cómo debe contestar el estado y el
gobierno y esto es una muestra clara de
esta representación de esta necesidad de
esta falta de tino del sistema político
como es generado en la actualidad por
otro lado ya habían prácticas de
partidos que encabezaban de hecho la
idea de combatir el sistema político o
muchas veces se podría hasta decir el
propio sistema democrático sin embargo
nunca había tenido
la fuerza en estas últimas elecciones
para colocar a un candidato de izquierda
en un primer lugar entonces esto sería
algo sui generis con la finalidad de
poder
manifestar claramente una tendencia
política por otro lado este voto de
protesta tendría un argumento
especialmente importante más ahora en la
pandemia en donde el perú ha tenido una
de las peores administraciones en
relación a todo todo este tema de
coronavirus entonces vamos a tener que
darles una una posibilidad muy
importante y quien compita con este
primer lugar que representa este
segmento de protesta de la población y
del votante va a tener que tener una
mayor sensibilidad porque básicamente no
ha habido una diferenciación entre los
candidatos políticos
cual haya sobresalido una oferta
electoral que tenga una propuesta real y
concreta de hecho muchos de los
candidatos han dicho todo lo que iban a
hacer pero jamás explicado el cómo lo
iban a hacer entonces esta influencia
evidentemente ante un votante molesto
ante un votante que ve que el sistema
político y democrático no funciona para
resolver los problemas básicos y más aún
que ahora la vida está estuvo de por
medio no está y lo estará evidentemente
la protesta y el descontento va a ser
mucho más profundo
clark y vemos que es notoria esa crisis
de representación allí en perú y sobre
todo la oferta de candidatos pues
confunde un poco también al electorado y
eso puede llevar a que haya un alto
porcentaje de indecisos de acuerdo a
encuestas allí en perú el 40% del
electorado de este país define por quién
va a votar en los últimos cuatro días o
en los últimos cinco días
a la fecha de la elección incluso para
este escenario político del día de hoy
muchos llegaron a las urnas sin saber
por quién votar un alto porcentaje de
los peruanos estaba indeciso veamos este
reportaje que preparó la redacción de
france 24
con serenidad del chase virgilio
martínez alista su restaurante en el
distrito turístico de barranco en lima
que hoy atiende al 30 por ciento de su
capacidad la crisis económica por la
pandemia del coi 19 lo dejó endeudado y
con múltiples pérdidas
estaba muy en deudas pero lo estamos
asumiendo como
y bueno la vida es así hoy en día toca
vivir y estamos viviendo con lo que
tenemos no sabe por quién votar el
próximo 11 de abril y se siente
resignado estamos de alguna manera
formateados a escuchar
discursos que sabemos que no sabemos que
serán aplicar en el instituto popular el
callado de la capital peruana el doctor
luís alberto núñez es cirujano en un
hospital público
él ha sido testigo del desinterés de los
gobiernos por mejorar la salud en el
país se siente desilusionado porque
ningún candidato tiene previsto aumentar
la inversión en el sector a pesar de las
deficiencias que la pandemia reveló y
esta decepción no solamente viene porque
la desinformación que existe no
solamente en los médicos sino también en
toda la población no hay mucho hay mucha
defraudación de cuatro los candidatos no
los partidos también se han venido abajo
agüita urbina es profesora de inglés
desarrolla sus clases por una plataforma
[Música]
en perú la mayoría de escuelas siguen
atendiendo a los estudiantes de manera
virtual sin que haya siempre los
recursos necesarios en las familias
dejando a muchos niños en el abandono
escolar que forma parte de los
ejercicios ya que no sé por qué
candidato o votar hay tantos candidatos
que realmente para uno le es imposible
indagar en cada candidato y también
sobre las propuestas que dan ninguna se
enfoca en lo que es la educación más de
25 millones de peruanos acudirán a las
ánforas en el momento más crítico de la
pandemia y después de un año marcado por
muchos escándalos políticos unas
circunstancias que podrían debilitar aún
más estas elecciones presidenciales
muchos candidatos indecisión y una
desconexión aparente entre los temas las
necesidades que tienen los ciudadanos
peruanos y lo que están ofreciendo
proponiendo los candidatos a raíz
después de la pandemia cover 19 que se
volvió un tema transversal y de suma
importancia en las campañas pero pocos
de ellos hablaron cómo iban a hacer
frente a la crisis de la pandemia de
kobe 19 regresó a lima con francisco
zacarías para un último reporte desde la
capital peruana antes de despedirlo en
este cubrimiento de france 24 para que
nos cuente el que dicen allí las
autoridades hay algunos resultados
preliminares esperamos un
pronunciamiento oficial adelante
francisco
y para contarles que la oficina nacional
de procesos electorales ha dicho que 11
y 30 de la noche van a emitir los
avances de los votos oficiales lo que sí
se está conociendo es las reacciones que
están teniendo los candidatos
presidenciales ellos también han
agradecido a los votantes que los han
posicionado pero no han emitido un mayor
digamos discurso ellos van a esperar
cada vía con prudencia que se produzcan
los proyecciones de lo que es las cifras
realmente oficiales los votos emitidos
lo que sí se está confirmando la
tendencia a través de los medios es que
el izquierdista pedro castillo tiene el
encabezado con el 16.1 por ciento
seguido por un triple empate entre el
derechista hernando de soto y keiko
fujimori con un 11.9 por ciento seguidos
por yonhy lescano con un 11.0 por ciento
los más abajo los siguen rafael lópez
aliaga con 10.5 por ciento verónica
mendoza con punto 8.8 por ciento todavía
no se puede hablar de triunfadores pero
lo que sí se puede dejar señalado es que
el nuevo presidente del perú que se
denomina el presidente del bc
bicentenario porque justamente éste
asumirá sus funciones el 28 de julio de
este año y cuando perú celebra los 200
años de su independencia pues bien este
presidente va a tener que asumir
desafíos entre ellos gestionar los 48
millones de dosis de la vacuna contra el
coi 19 que el presidente actual
francisco se haga así ya ha dejado
negociado con algunas compañías
farmacéuticas también deberá implementar
los hospitales con las unidades de
cuidados intensivos y el oxígeno porque
se ha establecido según diversos
analistas que a partir de junio va a
venir la tercera hora
kobe 19 y por si esto fuera poco también
va a tener que reactivar la economía
precisamente el producto bruto interno
del perú cayó 11 por ciento y va a tener
que generar las actividades productivas
promover el empleo producto de la
pandemia del coi 19 más de 2 millones de
peruanos perdieron sus empleos según
cifras oficiales pero hay otros
observadores que señalan que la cifra es
mucho más que estaría entre 6 o 7
millones de peruanos
el nuevo presidente va a tener que
construir un consenso
de acuerdos para llevar una nueva
políticas que permitan el desarrollo del
perú y negociar con un congreso
fragmentado
un escenario complejo francisco ya usted
lo decía 1.6 millones de casos de
contagio en perú la pandemia es sin duda
alguna el tema de importancia para esos
retos que va a tener el presidente que
llegue allí a la silla presidencial y
también el reto económico gracias
francisco por este último reporte desde
la ciudad de lima a las once y media de
la noche habrá un primer pronunciamiento
por parte de la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales que dará unos
resultados parciales o totales
dependiendo de qué tan rápido avance el
conteo de los votos pero ya francisco
nos daba unos porcentajes menores que
marcan que pedro castillos lleva el 16.1
por ciento de esos votos que son
resultados a boca de urna de acuerdo a
algunos algunas firmas encuestadoras
estaba hablando con erika y con eso
nuestros invitados para esta segunda
parte del programa sobre esa crisis de
representación que tiene perú y me
pregunta aquí es esta crisis estos
cuatro presidentes que ha tenido pero en
estos cuatro años esta desconexión que
hay entre autoridades
y ciudadanos nos lleva al surgimiento de
populistas de líderes populistas de
desconfianza de los candidatos
tradicionales de los partidos
tradicionales y lleva a la gente a
pensar porque no le doy mi voto a
alguien que me está proponiendo algo
distinto comienzo la ronda a la inversa
por enzo en la ciudad de lima
bueno el turismo en el perú ha tenido
trascendentalmente tres modos uno de
ellos ha sido el populismo el populismo
conservador a nivel de la historia luego
ha venido el populismo nacional y luego
el institucionalista que es el que
últimamente por lo menos ha puesto dos
gobiernos o dos fuerzas dentro del
gobierno
actualmente podríamos mencionar de que
este populismo tiene ciertos matices de
izquierda pero sobre todo termina siendo
dentro de una característica del
principio de la historia peruana de los
del sufrimiento de los populismos
clasificándose como nacionalista con
esta finalidad ellos se basan en
diferentes ideas una de ellas o
postulados uno de ellos por ejemplo es
el cambio de una nueva constitución
estamos hablando por ejemplo
y ver una situación mucho más atípica en
relación a haber prometido por ejemplo
que el sueldo del presidente va a
renunciar a dicho a dicho salario con la
finalidad de poder ganar lo que gana un
profesor en el país que actualmente es
uno de los sueldos más bajos a nivel
nacional entre otras cosas también ha
prometido una lucha desmedida contra el
crimen organizado y algunas otras
acciones en relación a incluso castigar
a los congresistas si éstos no se ponen
por encima de los de la del pueblo no si
éstos se están al margen del pueblo
recordemos que venimos de una historia
política muy golpeada en el último
quinquenio pues han habido vacancias
intentos de vacancias de instituciones
presidenciales y muchos cambios que han
originado
en evidencia una ruptura del sistema
político organizado por los propios
partidos políticos pues estos han
primado muchas veces más en su agenda de
intereses respecto de las necesidades de
la población y en evidencia en la
pandemia no se ha visto ningún tipo de
resultados ni de trabajos concretos
acerca de estas instituciones entonces
el resurgimiento de este tipo de
populismo es bastante claro está
radicalizando sé todo lo contrario a
alguna otra elección donde la izquierda
haya pasado a una segunda vuelta donde
busca por ejemplo acercarse al centro
con la finalidad de conquistar más votos
del espectro político en las
declaraciones por lo menos en las de hoy
día ha radicalizado más su mensaje
respecto al análisis que te puedo dar es
que si este candidato que estaba
actualmente en la primera en la primera
lista preferencial radicaliza más su
mensaje no tendría mucha posibilidad de
ganar con mayoría
la segunda vuelta el asunto de la
estrategia podría fallar le toda vez que
evidentemente hay una gran parte de la
población que también va a preferir que
continúe el sistema va a ser un colapso
de fuerzas pero mucho más que de
izquierdas de derechas
va a ser una situación que podría
aplicarse entre lo conservador y lo
liberal de muchos de muchas políticas de
gobierno que se va a empezar a plantear
seguramente en el transcurso de lo que
resta de la campaña hacia la segunda
vuelta electoral
erika en su opinión al respecto de este
surgimiento de posibles fuerzas más
populares ante el derrumbamiento del
establecimiento por múltiples razones
como lo estamos viendo acá este
descontento que hay cuál es su opinión
al respecto
bueno yo creo que es importante señalar
que los países andinos siempre han
estado proclives a la emergencia de
movimientos populares y naso nacional
populares acá en bolivia ha ocurrido
aquello lo propio ha pasado en el perú
pero con el agravante en el perú de que
han habido muchos episodios que han
terminado manchando a todo el sistema
político hay que recordar que es lo que
pasó el año 92 cuando se cierra el
congreso fujimori instala una autocracia
pero vertical y bueno la gente se
resiente muchísimo con el parlamento y
no dice absolutamente nada y bueno la
memoria es un autócrata autoritario que
tiene mucha popularidad ese es un tipo
de populismo el populismo que viene a
ser es un conjunto de estilo de decir
las cosas y hacer las cosas y de
gobernar que puede tener matices de
izquierda o de derecha pero en todo caso
apela a la fiba a la fibra afectiva de
la gente
es interesante lo que dice en su en
sentido de que en el perú la gente va a
buscar un centro más que posiciones
radicales de uno u otro lado aquí está
un desafío interesante para el perú
porque acá tendrán que pensar muchísimo
ese es ese parlamento fragmentado que
esa asamblea fragmentada que va a
acompañar al nuevo presidente que salga
de las urnas en una segunda vuelta
definitivamente de plantear el reto de
posibilitar la gobernanza la
gobernabilidad no solamente para
políticas de gobierno sino para perfilar
al perú hacia un nuevo ciclo que supere
este largo ciclo de una democracia
compartidos tan volátiles tan y tan
débiles con tantos problemas
estructurales y además con una muy baja
imagen ante el país importante ese peso
del congreso allí en perú
erika es importante ese apunte que usted
hace porque precisamente en estos cinco
años lo que hemos visto en la política
peruana es una
o un choque de trenes ya vuelvo y lo
menciono entre la presidencia y el
congreso del país vemos que el
presidente sabe que puede disolver el
congreso y el congreso sabe que puede
bajar al presidente lo hemos visto en
los últimos años y hay como una lucha de
fuerzas entre estas dos entre estos dos
puntos importantes de la política
peruana pero que no dejan que progrese a
la política del país veamos el siguiente
reportaje en donde vemos precisamente
esa conformación del congreso y cuál es
el peso que tiene en la política peruana
y en estos cinco años de tira y afloja
con la presidencia
las sociedades de américa latina están
cambiando en perú además de las
elecciones presidenciales el congreso
tendrá una nueva formación y entre sus
nuevos diputados podría estar angela
billón madre de cinco hijos que durante
35 años vivió en situación de
prostitución y lidera el movimiento de
trabajadoras sexuales de perú porque las
también votamos y decidimos dejar
de ser utilizadas para nosotras también
será autoridad pero autoridad en el buen
sentido la palabra para poder cambiar
nuestra realidad una diversidad que
llega a las personas trans gael a carl y
busca sus 28 años ser la primera
congresista trans de perú un camino
lleno de obstáculos y mucho compromiso y
sufrí en carne propia el éxito y las
consecuencias de la desigualdad de la
discriminación de la violencia de la
corrupción del extractivismo no es por
eso y hago política a estas candidaturas
comprometidas se les suman otras más
folclóricas como milagros suárez que
disfrazada de un personaje de dibujos
animados japonés y portando un peluche
pikachu hace campaña ya creemos que por
medio del anime del manga de cosplay y
también quizás el gaming se introduzca
en concepto de peruanidad se introduzcan
historias en base al imperio incaico un
mosaico diverso donde nos falta el
cristo cholo julio mario valencia es
famoso por vestirse de jesucristo y
recorrer las calles de lima cargando una
cruz en esta particularidad de esta
candidatura voy a levantar mi bandera de
la paz voy a levantar mi bandera del
perdón y voy a levantar mi bandera de la
reconciliación para que todos los
peruanos nos perdonemos unas elecciones
que a través de la diversidad muestran
que una nueva sociedad está llegando a
américa latina'
ahora hago la ronda a la inversa
comienzo con erika en la ciudad de la
paz
erika este tira y afloja entre la
presidencia y el congreso en perú estos
argumentos que ha dado el congreso
varias veces simplemente para quitarse
el camino alguno de los presidentes que
han pasado rápidamente de manera
interina y en perú afecta la democracia
golpea como lo hemos visto hasta ahora
la política peruana y sobre todo genera
mucho descontento entre los ciudadanos
como empezar a mejorar esa relación
bueno yo quisiera evocar la experiencia
que tuvimos en bolivia cuando se daba
situaciones en las cuales el presidente
no contaba con una mayoría significativa
en el parlamento y se daba la figura del
gobierno dividido la experiencia del
primer gobierno democrático que tuvimos
acá fue terrible y terminó evidentemente
con una primera crisis donde tuvo que
renunciar al presidente y adelantarse
las elecciones lo importante en este
caso y es la batalla de los liderazgos
que capten la necesidad de articular a
los actores en el parlamento se hace una
especie de presidencialismo parlamentar
izado donde el parlamento no entra en
esa guerra ya crónica y casi ritualizada
en contra del órgano ejecutivo porque
aquí no es problema que solamente pierde
la democracia la calidad de la
democracia el problema mayor está en que
los efectos que tiene sobre el
desarrollo y sobre la confianza de la
gente
las instituciones son tremendamente
fuertes son genocidas entonces lo más
importante en este caso y aquí viene ya
la responsabilidad del líder del líder
que empieza a interpretar esa sociedad
tan diversa estamos viendo la naturaleza
de los actores y también estamos viendo
en la necesidad de equilibrar lo que se
llama en política vida hoy día la el
ritual de la espectacularización de la
política las técnicas y las del estilo
de campañas que se están haciendo hoy en
día son altamente visualizadas más allá
que la propuesta se apela se apela a los
sentimientos de quienes se identifican
con estos nuevos sujetos que buscan
presencia en la política entonces el
presidente tiene que tener la capacidad
y la talla de liderar y de agregar
algunos intereses y una visión del país
a nivel del parlamento y hacer los
pactos y los acuerdos que
lamentablemente en tiempos de
polarización se han vuelto mala palabra
pero creo que hay que volver a ese
ámbito donde no es pecado
no es herejía el comenzar a conversar
con el otro una vez de que termine el
ciclo electoral y la estridencia que te
acompaña todo proceso electoral pensó la
construcción la escuchará el otro como
lo dice erika la talla de los liderazgos
también está en juego en las elecciones
de hoy 130 escaños del parlamento del
congreso en perú se puede construir una
relación cordial en presidencia congreso
dejar de estar pensando en disoluciones
y en vacancias y simplemente gobernar
bueno en realidad
en teoría lo que nos funciona erika
sería lo idóneo no pero lamentablemente
yéndonos un poco la práctica el mal
ejemplo de los últimos dos parlamentos
que fueron interrumpidos dentro del
quinquenio que nos está antecediendo
han demostrado y le han dado digamos esa
autonomía al parlamento para poder
enfrentarse con el ejecutivo
díaz y que haya un colapso de poderes
muy similar al que ocurre en europa por
ejemplo solo que nuestro sistema
evidentemente semi presidencialista y
normalmente o en situaciones normales el
parlamento pues elige después de una
vacancia un chisme al presidente de la
republica sabiéndose el parlamento y
teniendo esta práctica y aun así
teniendo una fragmentación de partidos
políticos que en la actualidad juega
también un punto en contra porque hay
grupos no solamente de izquierdas de
derechas sino de conservadores y
liberales y además quiero mencionar que
dentro de los candidatos políticos
dentro de los cinco primeros han habido
más de un populismo
el primer lugar el pedro castillo
evidentemente en este populismo nacional
pero también lópez aliaga por ejemplo
lleva un populismo e institucionalista
entonces hay una suerte de bloques que
se van a dar y de convergencias no
solamente de izquierdas y de derechas
hay propuestas conservadoras y liberales
etcétera entonces va a ser aún más
complejo porque estamos hablando de
muchos más elementos que van a micro
segmentar la política y ello frente a la
inoperancia de los partidos políticos
carentes la mayor parte de ellos de una
ideología el afinar a muchas personas e
incluso se han afiliado y han postulado
a los parlamentos sin una identidad
siquiera clara de su propio partido
político en cuanto a mi opinión
considero de que este parlamento va a
ser aún más difícil de los anteriores
quisiera creer que no y quisiera
que prime el diálogo como bien lo
mencionaba erika pero lamentablemente no
soy muy optimista frente a esta
situación buen punto en sus de que está
allí en lima en terreno conoce de
primera mano la situación importante
este apunte para los que estamos fuera
de las fronteras peruanas lejos de la
política de este país tal vez una de las
personas y de las figuras y caras más
conocidas dentro de estos cantidad de
candidatos que tienen para escoger los
peruanos a la presidencia está keiko
fujimori es una figura
internacionalmente muy conocida por ser
hija del ex presidente alberto fujimori
que gobernó durante una década a este
país suramericano también porque en una
de las elecciones pasadas cuando ganó
pedro pablo kuczynski pues lideró la
oposición con mano dura y lideró allí
una bancada opositora pero también luego
estuvo envuelta en diferentes casos de
corrupción estuvo incluso en prisión
preventiva por estar envuelta en este
caso de odebrecht y de diferentes
de corrupción así en perú es una figura
conocida veamos qué es lo que propone
keiko fujimori a los peruanos en este si
no estoy mal tercer intento por llegar a
la presidencia de perú
el ista chuquipoma es una fiel
simpatizante de keiko fujimori y no duda
de su voto el próximo 11 de abril
elisa disfruta tener como amuleto a un
panfleto con la imagen del expresidente
alberto fujimori quien fue condenado a
25 años de cárcel por violación de
derechos humanos no me considero una
calva la verdad porque me identifico
mucho con la señora que hay con la parte
que es mujer como ya sabemos sé que en
este si es que llega a ganar no nos va a
apoyar muchos acusan a la hija del
expresidente alberto fujimori de haber
dilapidado al bastión fujimorista que
diversos analistas calculan en un 30%
del electorado peruano consideran que
las crisis políticas que ocasionó al
poner en jaque a los expresidentes pedro
pablo kuczynski y martín vizcarra
respectivamente le generan un elevado
anti voto su estrategia es conquistar a
los electores indecisos y así pelear una
segunda vuelta al candidato hasta el
momento más opcionado yonhy lescano
estamos disputando el segundo lugar
le estamos poniendo mucha energía y
mucha alegría a pesar de toda la
situación tan dramática por la que está
atravesando nuestro país la pandemia del
cobi 19 golpeó duramente al perú
diversos sectores consideran que va a
ser muy difícil que la lideresa
opositora llegue a la segunda vuelta no
sólo por la excesiva cantidad de
candidatos a la presidencia sino también
por su complicada situación penal del
fujimorismo tal vez en estas elecciones
consiga unos 10 congresistas en un
congreso unicameral de 130 bancas en la
elección anterior tuvo 73 congresistas
la diferencia es abismal la caída es
bastante nos llega a extinguirse a
desaparecer pero si queda muy reducido
en su fuerza política elisa hecho cupo
mano se desanima sabe que mientras otro
fujimori lleven las riendas del
movimiento político se creará una nueva
generación de fujimori lovers
keiko fujimori una de estas candidatas
que aspira a la presidencia de perú la
destacamos acá porque es tal vez una de
las caras más conocidas a nivel
internacional de la escena política
peruana por ser hija del ex presidente
alberto fujimori quien está preso en
este momento y eso sus impresiones de
esta candidatura que como digo la
destacamos porque es una figura conocida
internacionalmente no es porque estemos
aquí haciendo defensa de alguno de sus
de sus proyectos
bueno
primero lo mencionabas
esta tendencia política conocida como el
fujimorismo viene en principio de
alberto fujimori su padre que
actualmente está preso y él representaba
al populismo conservador ella es también
una política populista conservadora
entonces lamentablemente vamos a caer
aquí entre elegir si es que keiko se
pasará a la segunda vuelta entre dos
tipos de populismo y ver cuál es el
populismo menos dañino aunque esto suene
utópico porque bien se los populistas
latinoamericanos terminan representando
no solamente un enfrentamiento con el
que va a tener el votante en la
actualidad que sería por ejemplo el
antifujimorismo que ella concentra que
es esa respuesta en contra de temas de
corrupción en contra de convivencia con
el narcotráfico en contra de muchos
otros elementos
encarnó su padre que fue positivo en las
políticas sociales y también en
políticas de privatización de empresas
que permitió además la inversión a una
mayor escala y elevó evidentemente al
país en índices macroeconómicos sin
embargo todo esto también tuvo ese
sentido negativo por el cual te lo
mencionó hace hace unos segundos
entonces al tener este este tipo de
situaciones podría verse la democracia
emplazada y amenazada a terminar por
elegir o por un mal menor o finalmente
porque se revele la mayor parte de la
población en contra del sistema político
el cual evidentemente termina colapsando
con este tipo de situaciones
bueno como les decía a las once y media
de la noche hora de lima vamos a tener
estos primeros resultados por parte de
la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales de perú conoceremos quiénes
son esos candidatos que pueden pasar a
la segunda vuelta o cuáles son los que
van marcando una tendencia el resultado
oficial pues no sabemos si lo vamos a
tener esta misma noche
debo dar paso a bolivia otro país que
estaba también en jornada electoral el
día de hoy cuatro departamentos de los
nueve que conforman este país estaban
eligiendo a los gobernadores y era una
elección importante para el partido
oficialista el movimiento al socialismo
más que quiere mantener allí el poder en
estos en estos pequeños bastiones a
nivel regional entonces pues damos paso
a la tercera parte de este especial
analizamos las elecciones en bolivia
y bueno está con nosotros erika desde la
paz ahora para hablar allí desde el
terreno desde conocimiento propio de la
política boliviana erika aquí está en
juego básicamente es el poder que puede
tener el partido más en su territorio en
las diferentes gobernaciones sus
impresiones sobre estos comicios y lo
que está en juego para este partido
[Música]
bueno es importante señalar que para el
más esta segunda vuelta era muy
importante porque intentaba reparar esa
sensación de derrota que tuvieron en las
elecciones en la primera vuelta de las
elecciones subnacionales si bien
originalmente pensaron que el impulso de
la victoria a nivel nacional iba a
mejorar el comportamiento electoral
respecto a otras elecciones
subnacionales eso no ocurrió entonces
esta segunda vuelta es una señal muy
importante para poder consolidar el
control territorial lo importante en
este momento es que que llama la
atención es de que evidentemente el
massey es es un partido al único partido
en bolivia que tiene una presencia a
nivel nacional y el problema es que ha
puesto toda la carne al asador ha
movilizado los recursos públicos la
presidencia ha dilatado a decisiones de
naturaleza política hasta después de las
elecciones para encarar la crisis
económica etcétera etcétera porque
precisamente el clima electoral
asumiría y enrumbarse a la gestión
pública propiamente dicha que se ha
puesto la carne al asador y
evidentemente parece ser por las
primeras tendencias que están reflejando
los resultados de que esta apuesta no ha
sido muy favorable habría que ver el
conteo final con punto final hasta el
día de mañana pero ya dos regiones una
de ellas tarija que fue realmente
disputada y estuvo el presidente evo
morales como jefe de campaña en persona
por allá y estuvo el presidente y
estuvieron absolutamente todos los
presidentes y las autoridades del más
señalando del que si ganaba el más en
ese bastión que nunca ha sido de nunca
pertenecido al partido de gobierno a
este partido predominante que sí y que
si no ganaba no iban a haber obras ni
una actitud cooperativa de parte del
gobierno central para con un gobernador
que no sea del másters estas señales
aparentemente no le gustan a la gente
fundamental y que escuchemos las señales
del voto que se va a dar en esta noche y
cómo se va a contabilizar porque si es
adverso al más en estas cuatro regiones
suban al menos dos de las cuatro que
están hoy día disputando la segunda
vuelta eso quiere decir que la
estridencia y la polarización y la
campaña tremendamente agresiva contra
sus adversarios no ha funcionado y ésta
también pone a prueba el liderazgo del
propio evo morales que fue cuestionado
por en movimientos internos otra
particularidad que tiene y aquí termino
santiago en estas elecciones es de que
si bien el más está disputando en la
segunda vuelta en los cuatro en las
cuatro regiones en tres de ellas los
candidatos que están en la contienda y
que se perfilan como ganadores son
candidatos que han salido de las filas
de almas han salido de las filas del
movimiento y del instrumento político de
los campesinos de los indígenas muchos
de ellos tienen una matriz indígena
nadie es el caso de chuquisaca que hace
mucho tiempo intentó y a él hace cinco
años pudo haber ganado pero maniobras
muy cuestionadas de parte del organismo
electoral determinaron evitar una
segunda vuelta
parece ser que condori me va a ganarla
esta gobernación no hay datos
contundentes ni oficiales sin embargo de
acuerdo al control electoral de algunas
de las tiendas políticas pareciera de
que al menos en tres regiones habría
ganado las oposiciones pese a las
amenazas de que si no ganaba el más no
habían obras si no había una relación
cooperativa este es el tipo de problemas
que se enfrentan en estos procesos
electorales en su aquí el escenario es
completamente opuesto en un sentido a lo
que estábamos analizando en perú y aquí
si hay un partido fuerte que se la está
jugando como decía erika el todo por el
todo por ganar en estas regionales
pero la polarización se mantiene el
remezón político que tuvo bolivia en los
dos últimos años fue histórico
contundente como analizar entonces la
situación de este país
bueno en el caso de bolivia hay una
clara tendencia o una clara mayoría por
preferir el sistema político de pronto
de izquierda mucho más que de derecha
podemos también hablar de que hay una
división de la propia izquierda dentro
de estas elecciones
erika nos mencionaba de que hay muchos
de las filas del más que están
participando en estas elecciones y que
están compitiendo contra el más
evidentemente por ejemplo esto se está
dando en una elección tan importante
como en la que se lleva en la paz en
donde pues un dirigente cuyo padre ha
fallecido y él ha continuado la senda
política
qué es maicon líder indígena tiene una
importante fuerza allí contra el más y
una oposición es muy fuerte además muy
poderosa en otros lugares quizás más
pequeños como pando el más si tendría
asegurado pero termina siendo una
distribución bastante pequeña con la
particularidad de colindar con brasil
por ejemplo y así como ella hay tarija
que está también justo colindando con
argentina y también hay una oposición
fuerte contra el más entonces estas
estas divisiones estas peleas internas
entre dos segmentos del populismo y que
están abocados a la izquierda
principalmente termina siendo muy
controversial no quizás mejores
posibilidades puedan tener en la cruz en
chuquisaca
vamos viendo de que no ha habido por
ejemplo mucha oportunidad con las
empresas encuestadoras para poder
anunciar mejores sondeos o sondeos
anticipados como se ocurrió en la
primera elección pero va a ser
trascendental y finalmente la derrota
del más en estas elecciones o el
predominio porque eso va a representar
una debilidad contra el partido de
gobierno y quizás un resquebrajamiento
en las políticas y acciones que podrían
empezar a tener un desenlace para el
presente y para un futuro inminente pues
ya veremos también los resultados de
estas elecciones regionales en bolivia
la autoridad electoral allí ha dicho que
los dará a conocer a lo largo de esta
semana no tenemos resultados tampoco
parciales oficiales que podamos darles a
conocer a nuestros televidentes
erika brockman y enzo helguera se me
acaba el tiempo ya llevamos más un poco
más de tres horas o tres horas de
transmisión ininterrumpida debo dejarlo
por acá pero
de haber estado con nosotros y habernos
dado detalles y análisis de la situación
política tanto en perú como en bolivia
les agradezco haber estado con nosotros
aquí en france 24 ustedes también les
agradezco por la sintonía habernos
elegido para informarse de este super
domingo electoral en los países andinos
ecuador perú y bolivia y va a cada uno a
sus respectivas elecciones
presidenciales y regionales importantes
para el desempeño político de este país
de estos países en nombre de todo el
equipo técnico de france 24 y también de
los periodistas de la redacción que
hicieron posible este especial les
agradezco la sintonía y haber estado con
nosotros sigan con la programación de
france 24